hey guys welcome back to the cloud
computing week by simply learn
previously on simply learns cloud
computing
popular frameworks like amazon aws and
microsoft azure today on day 4 as
promised we bring you the google cloud
platform gcp or the google's cloud
platform is a suit of cloud computing
services that runs on the same
infrastructure that the google uses
internally for its end user products
if you're in a worry that you missed out
the previous concepts that we discussed
in this cloud computing week by simply
learn don't worry all those sessions are
available on our official youtube
channel please feel free to check them
out
now before getting started with gcp let
me tell you guys that we have daily
updates on multiple technologies if
you're a tech geek in a continuous hunt
for latest technological trends then
consider getting subscribed to our
youtube channel and don't forget to hit
that bell icon to never miss an update
from saint leeron we will begin this
full course video with what gcp is
then we will look into gcp and its
concepts in detail then our expert will
give you a quick training on azure
services then we will see what's the
differences between aws and gcp next
we'll see what gcp web hosting is after
that we will be looking into google
cloud machine learning and finally we
will conclude this video by discussing
the google cloud platform fundamentals
certification training
so without further ado let's get started
with jcp good morning and good evening
everyone so welcome to this session on
google cloud platform my name is aj and
i'm an instructor with simply learn and
also working as a big data and cloud
architect for various clients across
globe in this session we learn about
google cloud platform wherein we will
learn about what is cloud computing why
google cloud platform what is gcp that
is google cloud platform
google cloud platform domains
about a use case that is federal use
case and also a quick demo on using
services from google cloud platform so
when we talk about google cloud platform
we also need to know what is cloud
computing so cloud computing is the use
of hardware and software components to
deliver a service to a network users can
access these files and applications
and services provided by a cloud
provider
from any device that has access to
internet
in short cloud computing is a way where
cloud provider provides
access to different services such as
resources and when we talk about
resources here we talk about computing
we talk about memory we talk about
processing power we talk about storage
and we also talk about different
services which cloud providers make
available for the users now that allows
us for automatic software integration
backup and restoring data unlimited
storage capacity having a reliable use
of different services and
having a cost efficient solution
now we know that cloud computing's
models there are different service
models so you have platform as a service
you have infrastructure as a service and
you have software as a service and these
are the prominent models which are
offered by different cloud providers
such as google cloud
such as google you have amazon you have
azure and also some organizations build
their own private clouds using open
source openstack
let's focus more on google cloud
platform and what it has to offer and
how it is gaining popularity in the
market with different organizations
which would want to work on
a cloud platform or which would want to
work
on
an infrastructure
which is modernized so when we talk
about cloud computing this is one of the
approach which organizations can take to
instantaneously benefit from
modernization
using different services different
platforms and also newer technologies
for their various requirements such as
scalability or dynamic businesses
before we get into google cloud platform
it is also
good to understand
where you can find some useful resources
about google cloud platform and here you
have a website which is
from your google cloud so this is
cloudacademy.com
slash library slash google and here you
can create a free account now that would
give you just seven days trial but that
has a lot of
videos which talk about your google
cloud platform and essentials and it has
various certification related videos
which you can access and then after
seven days after you have tried you can
obviously go for a paid account where
you can take detailed learning from here
now this is your training library which
shows your different cloud providers
such as amazon microsoft seo
gcp and then you have various other
topics which are specifics to
organization
you can obviously look at the pricing
and you can also look at resources which
will give you a good
experience in learning from these videos
you can also create a free account which
i will walk you through later so you can
create a free account on
cloud.google.com now when i say free
account that basically means it allows
you to create an account and every user
who creates an account gets a 300 free
credit which can be used to practice
brush up your skills and also explore
and learn about different
google cloud products which are offered
by google
now coming back to our google cloud
platform let's understand why google
cloud platform so google cloud platform
is popular for many reasons now let us
see few of most important reasons why it
stands out
when you talk about pricing pricing is
one of the significant factors that make
google cloud stand out among the other
cloud providers
it offers a monthly pricing plan which
is built according to monthly usage and
when we talk about billing here the
billing can be in hours it can be in
minutes and it can also be in seconds
there are different options when you
talk about your pricing which can be
found from your google cloud web page
now pricing could be
based on preemptive machines
pricing could be based on reserved
instances or reserved resources i'll
show you the link where you can find
more details on pricing part of it so
google cloud really has
various pricing options which help
customers in their different
requirements whether they would go for
any of the service models such as
infrastructure as a service platform as
a service or even software as a service
one more attractive thing about google
cloud pricing is that it provides
committed use discounts
for example under this scheme you can
purchase a specific amount of virtual
cpu cores
and memory for up to 57 percent discount
of
regular prices if you commit usage for
either one or three years now this is
just one option there are various such
options which you can learn about from
the google cloud page
and that really suits
different customers for their different
requirements
now when we talk about speed we don't
need to really challenge this aspect
when it comes to google services so
google provides its google cloud and
google app customer speed up to 10
terabytes because of its faster cable
system there are different kind of
machines which can be used if you are
talking about computation if you are
talking about memory hungry applications
or even storage intensive workloads
all in all speed is one of the defining
characteristics of google cloud services
the cable has connections over u.s west
coast
main cities in japan and even major hubs
in asia this speed enhances performances
and leads to customer satisfaction now
when we talk about customers any or
every customer would prefer to have low
latency
high throughput based services they
would want to use higher speeds to
process their data in as less time as
possible google provides a low latency
network infrastructure in fact you can
say that when you are using google cloud
services you are using the services from
the same infrastructure which google
uses for its popular services such as
google search or even youtube which is
one of the second largest repository
which can be accessed for videos now
when we talk about big data big data is
data which is
very complex has a lot of other
characteristics such as
your volume you have velocity you have
variety you have veracity validity
volatility virality and so on so if an
organization has is working on big data
google cloud can be a better choice
because google has many innovative tools
for cloud warehousing for example such
as bigquery and even real-time data
processing tools such as data flow
bigquery is a data warehouse that allows
massive processing of data at high
speeds
basically working on your structured
data google also has launched some new
machine learning from artificial
intelligence tools now there are various
other services which we can which we can
use from google cloud platform but let's
understand what is google cloud platform
and what are some of the services
even the services which are not listed
here can be found in your console from
google cloud so what is google cloud
platform gcp
it is a set of cloud computing services
provided by google that runs on the same
infrastructure as i mentioned that
google uses for its end user products
like youtube gmail and even google
search the various set of services
offered by google cloud platform are so
you have services which are specific to
computing requirements
and again in computing you have
various different options available you
have machines which are compute
optimized machines which are memory
optimized machines which are storage
optimized and also we have certain
machines such as pre m tiff which
basically means that you could get a
machine
to work on at a far
lesser price than any other machine but
when we talk about preemptive these are
the machines which can be requested on
demand and they can be taken back by
google at any time you have networking
related services
which can be very useful when you are
setting up your applications or your
services across globe you also have
different services which are specific to
machine learning and organizations which
would be interested in working on
machine learning or artificial
intelligence would be really interested
in using these services there are also
innovative solutions to work on big data
and big data related technologies
now when we talk about google cloud
platform domains so we can break down
these services into specifics such as
you have compute
now the compute service allows for
computing and hosting the cloud
now when you talk about computing here
there are different services
such as app engine you have compute
engine you have kubernetes you have
cloud functions and cloud run when you
talk about storage and database so the
storage and database service allows
application to store media files backups
or other file like objects now various
services under this are as follows you
have cloud storage cloud sql cloud
bigtable for unstructured data you have
cloud spanner cloud data store
persistent disks and cloud memory stored
when we talk about networking the
networking service allows us to load
balance traffic across resources now as
i mentioned earlier resources could be
your different resources which you would
be using from a cloud platform such as
your devices your instances memory
optimized or cpu optimized instances or
other resources creating dns records and
much more so various services under this
are vpc that stands for virtual private
cloud you have cloud load balancing
cloud armor cloud cdn you have cloud
interconnect dns and network service
tiers when we talk about the big data
service this allows us to process and
query big data in cloud
now various services under these are as
follows you have bigquery cloud cloud
data proc cloud composer cloud data lab
cloud data prep cloud pub sub which is
publish and subscribing system you have
cloud data studio now you also have the
developer tools and developer tools
service includes tools related to
development of an application now
various services under these are as
follows that is you have cloud sdk
software development kit you have
deployment manager cloud source
repositories and cloud test lab when we
talk about identity and security which
is one of the primary concerns for any
organization or any user who would be
interested in using a cloud platform
google cloud really has taken care of
this
so when you talk about identity and
security domain this deals with security
services now various services here
are cloud identity you have identity and
access management that is cloud iam you
have identity aware proxies you have
cloud data loss prevention api security
key enforcement key management service
and many more
you also have cloud services which are
related to internet of things so very
much would be used by organizations who
would be working on iot devices or the
data generated by these devices so
various services here
are cloud iot core you have edge tpu and
cloud iot also when we talk about cloud
ai that is artificial intelligence this
comprises of services related to machine
learning and much more so you have cloud
auto ml cloud tpu cloud machine learning
engine job discovery
dialog flow enterprise
natural language cloud text to speech
and much more
if you would be interested in services
related to api platform then there are
different services under this category
or this domain so you have maps platform
you have apg api platform monetization
developer portal analytics that is api
analytics apg sense cloud endpoints and
service infrastructure
so these are some of the listing of
services under each cloud platform
domain
now let's look at ferrero use case and
let's also understand what was done here
so ferrero is one of the famous
chocolate and ranks third among
worldwide chocolate and confectionary
producers it was found in
1946 in italy i'm sure you would have
seen the ferrero chocolates when you
would have gone out to buy some
chocolates so the challenges here was
that federal as we know is sold in every
supermarket and is known for its quality
once the business grew some issues arose
right and that's what happens when the
business grows you have issues popping
up which could be related to
the volume of data the speed with which
the data is getting generated the
variety of data and also looking at your
platforms which support
different dynamic applications or your
scalability requirements
performance requirements and so on
so it needed data storage processing and
analysis system for a wide customer
database
there was a huge gap between the company
and the people who bought its goats
because the company relied on data given
sales outlets now that's one of the
challenge
ferro wanted to create a digital
ecosystem where there was a point of
contact with its customers and also a
foundation for an innovative data-driven
marketing strategy what was the solution
here so one of the service of
cloud platforms or google cloud platform
is bigquery and this was an answer to
ferraro's challenges since it was
capable of hyper fast and efficient data
analysis as a solution
now as i mentioned bigquery is a data
warehouse which allows you to store
structured data now this could directly
be used as a service where you could
store in any amount of data and you
would not be paying for storage so there
are different pricing models and
for data
up to one terabytes you would not be
charged anything and if you would be
accessing the data that is reading the
data or processing the data from
bigquery that's where the pricing model
kicks in
now using google cloud's bigquery
business analysts of federal were able
to store and analyze massive data sets
in a very reliable fast and affordable
manner
consumer behavior and sales pattern data
reports were easy to build and automate
and the analysis also followed fairly to
adopt
advertising across various marketing
channels to serve the customer needs in
a better way what was the result
they could divide their database into
real-time actionable consumer clusters
to generate more accurate user profiles
ferro was also able to personalize its
marketing strategies to match the user
needs
now google cloud platform completely
tailored the website mobile content and
advertising
and created a very cost effective media
buy strategy
now these were some basics on google
cloud now as i said you can always find
lot of details about pricing
about services
and also all the services are accessible
in your free trial account now let me
just walk you through here so one is
you could always find details on
documentation on each of these services
so if i would click on getting started
you have quick start which basically
shows you short tutorials you have
trainings and you have also
certifications now if we click on quick
start
now that takes me to this page which
shows me
quick starts
or if you would want to understand about
different projects
if you would want to
look into the documentation of creating
a linux virtual machine or storing a
file and sharing it deploying a
container docker container image and so
on so you have a lot of quick starts
here
you can also look at cloud minute
on the same page on the right side you
have docs and once you click on that it
takes you to these
links now this shows you build solutions
which shows your top use cases best
practices all the solutions it's always
good to learn from these use cases which
are available and here you have
different feature products and all the
different services
which google cloud offers now you can
click on featured products
and that basically shows you a list of
these products now here we have all the
solutions which you can look at
architecture database enterprise level
big data and analysis gaming related
internet of things and so on now if you
go down here it shows you featured
products and that shows you
some of the important products such as
compute engine which is belonging to the
compute domain you have cloud run you
have anthus which is for migration
and basically cloud
adoption
when organizations would want to move
from on-premise to cloud-based solutions
you have vision ai you have cloud
storage now that basically allows you to
store any kind of data whether that's an
object so this is acting as an object
storage you have cloud sql which is
basically a ready to use
service where you would be using mysql
postgres or any other sql server
database services you have bigquery
which is a data warehouse which
basically allows you to store your
structured data
and then you have your ai and machine
learning related products so you have
auto ml vision ai video ai text to
speech speech to text and so on
now you also have different platform
accelerators which can be used and in
any of these cases for example if i
would click on compute engine
which is a featured product from google
cloud now that shows you
basically your quick starts
using your linux machines how to guides
which tells you completely working on a
vm instance
or working on storage working on
persistent disks and so on and it shows
you the documentation here now you also
have products and pricing option which
you can see for gcp pricing and you
could straight away go to the pricing
you could be looking at solutions which
talks about infrastructure modernization
now this is something which
organizations are interested in when
they would want to move from their
on-premise solution to your google cloud
now here i can say for example i click
on infrastructure modernization you can
always find some case studies what are
the different solutions we have here
right when you talk about google cloud
so you can always click on see solutions
and you can look at vm migration or sap
cloud right why google cloud what it can
be used for vmware as a service
or hpc that is high performance
computing and about these services we
will learn in detail later
now i can go back on the same page where
i was clicking on the services so you
have quick starts you have
how to guides you have deep
understanding of different concepts
right and here
if i click on all how to guides so that
shows me what are the different ways in
which you can work with compute engine
and working with different instances
although it's quite exhaustive content
but then if you follow steadily then you
can learn a lot about google cloud
now here i can just go back so this is
just giving you some idea on the
different products which are available
from google cloud looking into different
sections finding right documentation
here right and you can always look into
each one of these in detail for each
product which google cloud offers
now
if we scroll down we could see all the
options or all the domains which we see
here right let me just go back because
we got into solutions now we have quick
starts
right
and then you can basically scroll all
the way down to look at cloud sdk which
can be set up on your windows machine
like i have set it up on my windows
machine plus when you use google console
you have a gui which i'll show you in
couple of minutes and also a cloud shell
where you can use your command line
options to work with google cloud
platform you have cloud console which is
nothing but your gui to access your
resources now you can also look at
in-depth tutorials pricing and you have
different other options so let's just
click on pricing here and then we have
your price list which basically gives
you details of different services what
are available and what are the services
or what are the prices so for example if
i click on compute engine right and this
shows me the pricing aspect of compute
engine which belongs to compute domain
and here you can see you have vm
instance pricing you have networking
pricing sole tenant nodes which are
specific to particular organizations or
if organizations would want to have
dedicated nodes you have gpu based
pricing right so general processing
units you have disk and image pricing
and you can click on any of the links
and you can see
pricing which also shows you your
different kind of machine types so here
you have different kind of machine types
which says n1 n2 n2d e2 you have memory
optimized machine types you have compute
optimized you have premium images and
you can basically look at all the
categories you can look at disk pricing
which involves your persistent disk
pricing for ssds or sdds what are the
kind of images what are the different
network services right and you can
always look at
your machine types you can choose a
particular region right there is the
concept of region and availability zones
here and as per region you could look at
the prices
you can also look at standard prices you
could be looking for what are the free
tier machines if i'm specifically
looking for vm instance pricing i can
click on this one and that takes me to
the vm instance pricing what is the
billing module what is the instance up
time what is the resource-based pricing
and then you can also look at different
kind of discounts such as sustained use
discounts committed use discounts
discounts for preemptable vm instances
and so on and this is how you can be
looking at pricing for all different
resources and you can choose the
resource which you are interested in and
then look for the pricing benchmarks
reservations if you would want to use
and you would want to benefit if you
would want to look at what are the
quotas and limits and so on so please
explore this link and you can find lot
of information when it comes to
technical options looking at different
google cloud products which we briefly
discussed when it comes to domains
and what each product can be used for
you can always come back to the main
page where i was showing you different
services we went into pricing straight
away right now you can always come back
to this page
on your
cloud.google.com and then you have your
solutions
which talks about different products
right and you can click on these or you
can look into technical documentation so
this talks about your different featured
solutions infrastructure solutions you
have data center migration related and
so on so i could be talking more and
more about google cloud platform it's a
ocean it's a huge chunk of different
services for different organizational
requirements so look into this link and
also what you can do is create a account
on gmail i mean you could create a free
account or you could go to
cloud.google.com and then you could
create a free account like i have
created here and i can just click on
console now that's my gui or google
cloud console which basically allows me
to work with google cloud now there are
a lot of options here by default when
you create an account now in my case on
the top it says it's a free trial
account i have 300 credit and out of
that 251 dollars is left and 237 days
out of a year are left for my account
now here i can basically see the project
right and by default we can create a
project or by default there is a project
existing for any user so when you log in
it creates a particular project and you
could create a new project and project
would be to dedicate your different
services or different resources per
different project so this is your
dashboard which basically shows your
project which shows you a project number
and a project id which is always unique
now you can click on this and this if
you would want you can hide this
information you can also look into the
documentation part of it then it shows
you the different services or a
graphical information of services which
you might have used in past so you have
compute engine which shows you how much
percentage of cpu was used you can
always go to compute engine as a service
you can look at your google road
platform status and look at the google
cloud status now this is billing now
since this shows me the billing period
for april month and i can always look at
detailed charges i can look at reporting
i can look at different apis which
google offers
and
for your different kind of work you can
always go to the api overview or the api
link and enable or disable any api now
once you enable or disable any api then
you can use that so you have news
section you have documentation and you
have getting started guides which tells
you how to work or enable different apis
if you would want to deploy a pre-built
solution add dynamic logging monitoring
errors deploying a hello world app and
so on now this is your dashboard i can
click on activity and that would show me
what kind of activity i would have done
in my cloud platform i can always choose
the kind of activities
by saying activity type i can choose the
resources now it shows me that i created
some vm instances i deleted them
i
updated some metadata i basically worked
on instances i changed some firewall
rules here i have then also worked on
some other services or apis so i created
some buckets which is for object storage
and again i have been working with some
instances and creating some firewall
rules here i have granted some
permissions i am setting up a policy
right so this activity gives me a
history of what things i have done over
the past couple of months
while working on google cloud platform
now
on the top left corner you have the
hamburger menu which you can click on
this so that's your navigation menu and
when you click on this this shows you
home it takes you to the marketplace it
specifically takes you to billing you
can always look at apis and services so
here in api services i can pretty much
go to a dashboard and i can see a report
on the traffic or errors or latency
and the kind of apis which are available
so you have compute engine api
you have bigquery api bigquery data
transfer api bigquery storage cloud data
proc so these are some of the apis or
services i've used in past might be i
was evaluating a product might be i was
using a particular product so you have
whenever you would want to use a
particular service from google cloud
platform you would be enabling these
apis so here we see some apis for data
proc you have
logging monitoring you have resource
manager api you have cloud sql which
allows you to directly use mysql or
postgres you have cloud storage
right and so many apis
so if i would want to enable a
particular api which is not right now
required but then it's good to know you
can always click on this one you can
search for an api so for example if i
would say data proc right and that shows
me the cloud data proc api which manages
hadoop based clusters and jobs on google
cloud platform so i can spin up a hadoop
cluster and i can start running some
jobs on a hadoop cluster on demand and
as i'm done with it i can just get rid
of it so this is an api which i would
have to enable and then for every
particular service you also have an
admin api which you would enable
now going back so coming out from this
api library i got into api and services
now there is you can look into the
library you can look at credentials and
you can also look at
different time intervals for which you
can see the usage of your different apis
now going back to the menu you have
support
wherein you can always reach out to the
google support team if you are using a
paid version even with free trial you
can try to reach out and you will find
someone to help but it is always good
when you have a billing cycle reaching
out the customer care
you have identity access management in
admin and this is required when you're
working with different apis or services
when you would want to have relevant
access you have getting started you have
security related options you have anthos
which is mainly for migration now here
you can look at your different domains
such as which we discussed so you have
compute and in compute you have
different services so you have app
engine you have compute engine
kubernetes you have cloud functions and
cloud run you can look into the storage
aspect which shows you big table which
is usually and mainly for your
unstructured data big table which is
something which gave rise to
popular nosql databases like hbase and
cassandra you have data store which can
be used you have firestore file store
storage which can be used to put in data
of any kinds you have sql for structured
data you have spanner as a service you
have memory store and you have data
transfer
now when it comes to the networking
domain you have all these services such
as vpc virtual private network
network related services for your load
balancing for using a cloud-based dns or
cloud defined network you have hybrid
connectivity network service tiers
security and intelligence
then you have other options for your
operations which can be used and here
you have different other tools which can
be used such as cloud build
you have cloud tasks
registry deployment manager and many
more
big data specific you have the services
here so you have data proc which can be
used to spin up your clusters you have
publish subscribe messaging system such
as now kafka which you might have heard
of originates its idea from here so pub
sub you have data flow you have iot core
bigquery which is a data warehouse
package or data warehousing solution
from google cloud
now then you have your artificial
intelligence related services and other
google solutions
so you can always find a huge list of
services or you can say at high level
solutions offered by google cloud
and we can use these to basically test
some of the solutions use them and work
on them so i'll give you a quick demo on
different services which can be used
here from your google cloud platform now
this is your google cloud platform and
this is your console now this also gives
you a cloud shell which can be activated
so that you can work from command line
and you can always find a lot of
documentation on that so you can also
set up your cloud shell that is sdk on
your windows machine and if you have set
it up then basically you could be doing
something like gcloud
right if the cloud has been set up so in
my case
i had set up the cloud sdk and basically
i can get into that
by looking at what path i have set up so
cloud sdk and then i can be using it
from my windows machine as per my
comfort i can also activate the cloud
shell here which will basically open up
a terminal and at any point of time you
can open up this one cloud shell in a
different window it is preparing the
cloud shell where it will by default set
up your project it will set up the
metadata and now i am logged into my
google cloud account from command line
and here i can basically use gcloud
right and that basically shows you the
different options which are available
which you can be using so if you would
want to use a particular service you can
also try giving a help and that shows
you how do you manage your google cloud
platform right so you have different
options for billing
to work with your different services and
basically you could be working on google
cloud using this cloud shell from your
command line
usually for people who are learning or
cloud in the beginning it is always good
to go for console and use your different
services from here in an easier way but
as i said you can always use the command
line for example if i would just go
ahead and type gcloud
create
instances
and that will directly take me to the
cloud console documentation which shows
you different options which you can use
to work with instances so i could do a
gcloud compute instances create and then
i could give my instance name and so on
and i'll show you some examples on that
so you can be using your cloud console
right that is your cloud shell and you
can straight away start working from
command line however i would suggest
using console in the beginning and when
you are well experienced then you can
start using cloud shell to do things
from command line and when you are fully
experienced you can always switch and
certain things are usually useful or
easier when done from command line and
some are easier when you do it from the
console and you can use any one of these
options now we can go to google cloud
console now as of now i can close this
one i still have my cloud shell open if
i would want to look into it i can click
on this one and i can straight away go
to compute engine where i would want to
work on creating some instances on
google cloud platform using the compute
engine service
and then basically connecting to those
instances and basically trying out some
basic things so you can click on vm
instances and then once this comes up i
can always create some instances now if
you see here i have some instances
already created right and i can continue
working on those i can create new
instances i can use different options
while creating instances and i'll show
you that in a demo in quick seconds
so let's have a quick demo on setting up
gcp instances now before that let's have
a quick recap so when you talk about
instance or a virtual machine it is
hosted on google's infrastructure right
and you can create your google cloud
instance using this google cloud console
that is by clicking on this and then
going to compute engine and clicking on
vm instances now you can also do that
from google cloud command line tool that
is cloud shell and you can be doing that
using compute engine api
so compute engine instances can run the
public images for linux or windows
servers
that google provides you also have
option of creating or using custom
images that you can create and import
from your existing systems you can
deploy docker containers which are
automatically launched on instance
running containers optimized os
now when you talk about instances and
projects always remember that in each
instance belongs to a google cloud
console project and a project can have
one or more instances
when you talk about instances and
storage options each instance has a
small boot persistent disk which i will
show you in further screens
that contains the os you can add more
storage space if needed
and when you talk about instances and
network a project can have up to five
vpc networks so vpc network is virtual
private networks wherein you can virtual
private cloud networks where you can
have your resources within your own
subnet
and each instance belongs to one vpc
network
now instances in same network can
communicate with each other through
local area network protocol an instance
uses internet to communicate within any
machine so that could be virtual
physical or outside its own network when
you talk about instances and containers
you should remember that compute engine
instances
support a declarative method for
launching your application using
containers
now you can create a vm instance or a vm
instance template
you can provide a docker image and
launch the configuration
so there are different ways in which you
can create these instances and once you
create these instances you can say for
example you are creating a linux
instance you can associate ssh keys with
your google account or your g suite
account and then manage your admin
non-admin access to the instance using
im roles if you connect to your instance
using gcloud or ssh from console which
we will see later compute engine can
generate ssh keys for you and apply that
to your google cloud or g suite account
now what we can do is we can see how we
can create your google cloud instances
from your console or from the command
line let's have a look in creating
instances using gcp console now that we
have learned on some basics of google
cloud platform what are the different
services what are different domains
basically looking at your google cloud
console or even cloud shell
let's go ahead and create some vm
instances now that's from your compute
engine service and let's try connecting
to these instances and see how this
works let's also see what are the
different options which are available
when you would want to create the
virtual machine instances here so when
you click on your drop down from the top
left and choose compute engine so it
brings you to this page so i can show
that again so you can click on compute
engine click on vm instances and that
basically brings you to this page now
here it tells you compute engine lets
you use virtual machines that run on
google's infrastructure so we can create
micro vms or large instances running
different distributions of linux or
windows using standard images that is
public images and you can also have your
own image so let's create a vm instance
by clicking on create
now that's basically helping me to
create an instance here so it shows me
the instance name i can give it
something so let me say c1
now i can add labels so what is label it
basically allows you to organize your
project add arbitrary labels as key
value pairs to your resources this so
this is basically categorizing
your labels and projects if you have
multiple projects now remember if you
have your cloud console and if you have
created your free trial account it will
allow you to do these things if not you
may have to go back to the billing
section and see if the billing is
enabled which also means that when you
are creating your google cloud account
it will ask you to key in your credit
card details but they do not charge
anything or they might charge might be
one dollar or one rupee depending on
your location and that's also refunded
but that's just to verify your card now
once i've given the name i can choose a
region so i would basically choose
europe since i'm in europe i would be
clicking on europe west 3 and here i can
choose an availability zone availability
zone is basically to make your services
or instances or any other resources
highly available so you can choose one
of the availability zones now i would
choose save s3 now this one we can
scroll down and here it says machine
configurations you have general purpose
machines you have memory optimized
machines which is m1 series and you can
always go back to the google cloud page
and see
what a particular kind of machine
specializes in so i would click on
general's purpose and in general purpose
you have different categories so you
have n1 which is powered by intel
skylake cpu platform or you have e2
which is cpu platform selected selection
based on availability so let's have n1
selected now this one shows me the
machine type and if you are using your
free tier account then you can start
with collecting a micro machine which is
one virtual cpu core you can go for a g1
small which is one virtual cpu core and
1.7 gb ram you can even go up to a
high-end machine and then you can
basically see if you are using a free
account how many of these machines you
can use if i would be selecting eight
virtual cpu cores and 32 gigabyte of
memory then it would allow me to create
at least two instances by this
configuration we will use n1 standard
which is one virtual cpu core 3.75 gb
memory now then we can also deploy a
container image to this vm instance if
you would be interested in deploying a
container image let's not get into that
right now
here it shows you the boot disk and it
shows you dbn gnu 9 linux 9. what i
would do is i can go for this
distribution or i can choose a linux
distribution of my choice so here you
have public images you have custom
images you also have snapshots if you
have created backup of your previous
images here i can choose for example
ubuntu and then i can choose a
particular version so let's go for
ubuntu 18.04 you can go for the latest
one also 18.04 would be good enough
and here it tells me what is a boot disk
so you have ssds or you have standard
persistent disks now ssds are little
expensive in comparison to your standard
persistent disks or your sdds but then
ssds are faster so as of now we can
choose standard persistent disk as it is
and we can let the gigabyte be 10 now
depending on your requirement you can
increase this you can even add disks
later that's not a problem click on
select now here i have access scopes so
here i will say allow default access you
can also set access for each api or you
can give full access to all cloud apis
so that based on your requirement you
can any time change later also we will
also say allow http traffic and we can
also choose allow https traffic that
basically allows me to access this
machine or services which are http based
accessible from this machine now i can
just click on create however it would be
good to basically enable connectivity to
this machine now we can do that in
different ways one is when you bring up
your machine it will have an ssh access
which you can log in from the cloud
platform here itself or what you can do
is you can create a private and a public
key using some softwares like putty or
putty gen so for example if you do not
have that on your machine you can
download you can just type in download
putty that takes you to the putty.org
page and here you can click on download
putty and scroll down which shows you
for your 64-bit machine which i have in
my case you can download putty.exe which
is basically your ssh and telnet client
to connect to your machines you can also
use putty gen which will be allowing you
to create a private and a public key
which i have done in my case let me show
you how so what you can do is you can go
to puttygen to begin with and here you
can click on generate now then to have
this key generated just move your cursor
on the top here in the empty space and
that creates your key you can give it a
name so for example let's give a user
name i would give hdu now i can give a
password for this one so let me give a
simple password
and what i can also do is i can copy
this public key from here and for my
later usage i can just keep it in my
notepad file which i can use later and
i'll show you when
so now we can save this private key and
this will basically allow me to save my
private key i can choose desktop and i
can give it a name so let's say
new key
new key and that will be getting saved
in a dot ppk file
so let's save it and that's done so we
also have our public key and we have
saved our private key now we know that
when you would want to connect using ssh
you need your private keys to the client
and public key also has to be existing
so let's take this public key so let's
do a control a i'm going to copy this
and i'm going to come back to my google
cloud console and here you can click on
security so you can click on the
security tab here scroll down and just
give your public key once you give that
it resolves and shows you the name and
this is good enough so that i can use my
ssh client to connect to this machine i
can click on create and this will
basically create my vm instance it will
take some time and then your instance
will have an internal ip which will show
up here external ip and it will also
show you options to connect to these
machines so this is my internal ip this
is my external ip which i can use to
connect from a client i can easily
connect from the option here which says
ssh and i can say open in a browser
window i can even open this in a custom
port i can look at the gcloud command
which you can give from cloud shell or
you can use another ssh so let's first
do a open in browser window and let's
see if this connects so we can easily
connect to our instance in the ubuntu 18
instance which i just set up here easily
in couple of seconds now this is trying
to establish a connection using your ssh
keys
and when you do that it also basically
brings up this web browser so i'm
already connected it shows my username
which is my cloud account username and i
have been connected to this machine here
using ssh it did not ask me for any
password and basically now i can just
check what do i have in my linux file
system right and i can anytime login as
root by doing a sudo su for example
let's try installing a package and i can
say apt get installed vim
or app get installed wget
or apt-get install
open ssh and all these packages are
already existing so not an issue now i
can start using this instance i can just
look at the disk what is available okay
now we gave around 10 gigabyte out of
which we see 8.3 gigabyte here
for the dev sda1 and then 1.8 gigabyte
available and you can continue using
this machine this was the easiest way of
connecting to a vm instance using ssh
now what we can also do is i can just
leave this and i will now try to connect
using an external ssh client right and
here you can copy the public ip so when
you want to connect to an instance you
will have to get the public ip also
remember that if you select and stop
this machine which will stop your
billing counter and if you start it
again the internal ip will remain same
but the external ip is the one which
will change
i can obviously select this machine
anytime and i can do a cleanup and i can
delete it
i can do a start of the machine if it is
stopped and i can even import the
virtual machine to be used later so
there are different options which you
can always use
so this is my instance and if you would
want to look at the details click on
this one c1 and that should basically
allow you to look at the details so it
shows you what is the instance id what
is the machine type is it reservation
specific what is the cpu platform what's
the zone and all the other details
at any point of time if you would want
to edit you can always click on edit and
you can change the details as you need
now you can also look at the equivalent
rest command to basically use the rest
api to connect to this instance for now
i have copied the public ip and i would
want to connect it using putty so let's
go in here and let's give it the host
name so i can give ubuntu i can give my
ip address so that's in my session now i
will click on ssh i would go into
authentication i'll click on browse and
this is where i need to choose the ppk
file so this is the one which we created
new key let's select this
and then i can come back to session i
can even save this and i can call it as
my instance one
let's save it and you can create any
number of instances so you see i have
created different instances here for my
google cloud or amazon related instances
and i can click on open it says the
service host key is not cached in the
registry that's fine just click on yes
and basically it says
no authentication method supported now
this could be because we have not
enabled your ssh access so let's look at
that so now let's see if we were trying
to connect using putty what was the
issue here so if i go back to my
putty select my instance load it it says
port 22 i'm giving the username which is
ubuntu or sorry that's the wrong
username we gave and that might be the
reason we had set up the user ssdu so
let's save this again and now let's try
connecting to this one and it asks for
my password and you are able to connect
this right now if there was any other
issue related to network connectivity
then we could look at the rules the
inbound and outbound rules which allow
us to look into the machine now we are
connected to our machine here using hdu
user i can login as root and i can
continue working
so not only from the ssh within the
cloud console but you can use an
external ssh client and connect to your
machine so this is your ubuntu machine
and we can basically look at the space
and that basically confirms we are
connecting to the same machine which
shows 8.3 gigabytes here and 1.8
gigabytes here which we were seeing from
the ssh in the browser now let's close
this and let's go back to our instance
page now here you can always look at the
network details and this will show you
your different kind of rules that is
ingress or egress rules which basically
allows to connect to this machine from
an external network or for this machine
to connect to an external network so
here we have different firewall rules
which shows default allow http that's
your ingress rule and it tells you apply
to all it shows me what are the ip
ranges where i can specifically give the
ip of my machine it shows the protocols
it shows what are the different ports
which you have used for these services
for example rdp or ssh which shows 22
you have icmp http and https now anytime
if you would want to make a change to
these rules that can be done by going
into your network details
and say for example you would want to
work on firewall rules so we have these
firewall rules here you can click on
this one so right now we are looking
into the network domain and we are
looking into vpc network right and this
shows me what are the different rules we
have now if i would want to create a
different firewall rule for a different
protocol i can always click on create
firewall rule i can give it a name okay
i can say
what if you would want to turn on the
firewall logs you can basically say what
is the kind of traffic so ingress
applies to incoming traffic and egress
applies to outgoing traffic and you can
then basically choose what are the ip
ranges from where you want that
connection to be coming in or to going
out you can choose a particular protocol
you can give a protocol
here with comma separated values and you
can create a firewall rule so this might
be required depending on the services
which you are running wherein you might
want to enable your access to your
machine from an external service or to
an external service so you can always go
to network details from here you can
then go into firewall rules create a
firewall rule apply that to your
instance and restart your instance so as
of now we don't need to create any
network details here because my ingress
or egress rules are already available
right now i can basically then have my
instance stopped and removed so i can
just do a stop or since this is running
the ideal wave would be to do a stop i
could also do a reset now what does
reset do reset does not basically delete
the machine what it does is it does a
cleanup of the machine and it brings it
to the initial state so sometimes we
might have installed certain things on
our machine we would want to clean them
up and at that time reset can be useful
i can basically click on delete right
and i can select this and i can do a
clean up and this is good always when
you are using a free trial account try
to use different services play around
with them and then you can clean up so
that you do not waste your free billing
credit right and you can use it for
meaningful stuff
now i have clicked on delete and within
few seconds my instance which i had
created will be deleted also to remember
is if you are creating multiple
instances
then you can connect from one machine to
other machine using ssh by using the
private file so for that we can learn in
detail later so this is just a simple
example of using your compute engine
creating your instances connecting to it
from an internal ssh or from an external
ssh client such as putty where you have
already created your private and public
keys now i can click on the browser here
and then i can basically come out and i
can basically be looking into any
particular service so we just looked
into compute engine right you have
different other options you have
instance groups you have instance
templates for example let's click on
instance templates here and that
basically shows you that you don't have
any instance template and this basically
facilitates say for example you are
working as a admin and you would want to
create an instance template so that
using that you can describe a vm
instance and then you can basically use
this template to create different
instances
you can go for sole and notes you can
look for machine images you can also
look at your disks you can create a
snapshots and you can look at different
options here now let's come back here
and let's click on home and that should
take you back to your home page which
basically shows you if a particular api
which you have used recently which shows
me in the graph here
so i can go to the api's overview right
and that basically shows me if there
were any errors
if i was using the compute engine api to
basically create a vm instance and
that's why we were seeing some spike in
the graph
so this is a quick demo of using your
compute engine service provided by
google cloud wherein you can create vm
instances and use those vm instances for
your application installation for any
other purpose
now that we have seen how you use
your cloud console to create an instance
and also clean it up
let's also understand how you can do
using your command line options and
let's see what it takes or what are the
different commands which you can use to
create your instances
now you can always when when you're
creating an instance you can use compute
engine which provisions resources to
start the instance so instance basically
has different states which we can see
when we are creating the instance
so you basically start the instance
instance moves into staging that is
prepared for your first boot
finally it boots up and then it moves
into running so when you look at instant
states which we will create instance in
c
it will basically have different states
such as provisioning where resources are
being allocated for instance but
is not yet running then it goes into
staging where resources have been
acquired an instance is being prepared
for your first boot then instance
is booting up and running and if you are
stopping an instance it goes into being
stop status and it would be moved to the
terminated option you can also do a
repairing of instance and finally you
can terminate your instance or clean it
up by stopping and then deleting it
now when you say stopping and resetting
an instance you can stop the instance as
i showed earlier if you no longer need
it but if you need for future use you
can just use the reset option which will
basically wipe the contents of instance
or any application state and then
finally you can stop it and have it
terminated now when you would want to do
that using your cloud console or we have
seen the options now let's also see from
the command line tool how you can do it
so here i have the cloud shell which i
brought up from here and i basically
opened it in a new window so command
line tool enables you to easily manage
your compute engine resources in a
friendlier format than using your
compute engine api now gcloud which is
part of cloud sdk is the main command
here and then you can always auto
complete the different options here so
when you would want to create or work on
gcloud you can just type in gcloud here
and then for example
i could just say help to see different
options of g cloud which will show me
different options which you can use here
now we would be interested in compute
instances so i could also do a g cloud
compute
compute
instances and then i can basically say
create and then i can do a help now that
should show me different options which
work with gcloud compute instances
create command
which is expecting an instance name
so your google cloud sdk
which we can set up on our windows
machine or even on your linux machine is
set of tools that
helps you to manage resources and
applications
hosted on your gcp that is your google
cloud platform now here you have options
such as gcloud which i am showing you
right now you have gsutil and then you
have bq so that also can be used so you
can set up a google cloud compute if
using gcloud
now what we can do is
if we are setting up our sdk on our
windows machine then we would have to do
a gcloud init which basically
initializes
your configurations for g cloud
now here we are using a cloud shell
which was started from the console and
we don't have to basically give your
gcloud init command because it's already
initialized now you can always look at
your default zone you can look at your
region what is being used all those
things are coming from the metadata
which is being used so for example i
could be looking at the metadata for my
particular project by just doing a g
cloud and then i can say compute
and i would be interested in project
info
so i can just do a project minus info
and then i can do a describe
and then i need my project id so i can
say minus minus project
and i can get my project id from here so
you can click on this one
and that's my project id so i can click
on this one and here i can just do a
right click and if it does not paste
then you can do a control v
and then i can try to look at my project
info so this basically will give me the
metadata which is by default set and we
can always look at what are the regions
or what is the zone which has been set
so if it has been set so i'm looking at
my details it is showing my ssh keys
and then it can be using your default
region and your default available zones
it also shows my username and other
details so this is basically to look at
the metadata which is available now at
any point of time i can basically say
add metadata i can basically choose
metadata option and i can say my default
region should be europe which i was
choosing earlier so i can just bring up
this command again and what i can do is
i can say here where i have gcloud
compute project info where i did it
described earlier now what i could also
do is i can just say add metadata
and then i can specify what is the
metadata i would be interested in adding
i can then say google compute
default
region
and then i can basically give a region
for example europe
and then i can say west 3
and if you are not well experienced you
can always do it from console or you can
be doing it from here so i'm giving
google cloud compute google compute
default region then i can also give a
google compute default zone
and then i can pass in a value for
default zone so i can say europe
west 3
and then basically i can give an
availability zone so if
it is basically giving me some error
where i'm trying to pass in these values
so i can just give it this way and then
it basically says that if you can look
into particular help to see what is the
command which you would have to do now i
can basically do a g
cloud
init here initial configuration and this
basically says that it is initializing
my
default configuration it says
reinitialize this configuration from
cloud shell
you want to create a new configuration
so if i had updated my
metadata
then basically i could just do a cloud
in it
and i could be re-initializing my
default configuration or properties
which i have passed in so as of now i
will not activate or change the default
region let's go for a simple way in
which you can create your compute engine
so for example i'll just say one and it
is re-initializing it asks me what is
the user name
and let's select that it says what is
the project
and let's select that
and do you want to configure a default
compute region and zone right and i will
just say yes
and basically then it shows me different
options which we have here
so there are too many options here and
then here we were interested in
europe west 3 so let's choose 21
right and then that basically allows me
to choose my region and my zone so it
also gives you some specifications so it
says your project default compute zone
has been set to europe s3a you can
change it by running gcloud config set
and you can give a compute zone right so
i can always give these commands i can
get help information here so i can just
say gcloud config set and i can be
specifying the compute zone so i can say
compute slash zone and i can give a zone
i can say compute slash region and i can
give a region name if i would want to do
it or the easier way is like what i did
right now so you can basically do a
command gcloud in it and then basically
it allows you to change your
configuration or set default things here
you cannot all the times you can say
gcloud config unset
to basically remove a compute zone or a
compute region now there are different
ways so if you were working on a linux
machine you could always
use an export command something like
this so you could do export compute
sorry cloud
sdk
and then you can say compute underscore
zone
and then give your zone name or compute
underscore region and give your region
or you could add it in your bash rc file
right now that is when you have your
cloud sdk set setup on your linux
machine or on windows machine and you
would want to specifically set a zone
and a region for all your compute
related resources so we don't need to do
that the default settings are already
given here right
and what we can do is we can start by
quickly looking into
gcloud compute instances options so i
can say gcloud
compute
instances
and then i can just do a list at any
point of time if you would need help you
can just do a gcloud compute and then
say minus minus help or i could just do
a gcloud compute and that shows me
different options which i have here from
which i use instances
i can always type instances and again
hit enter and it shows me different
options what you would want to do so i
can initially just type list which
should show me what are the
or what are the instances available and
as of now we don't have any instances i
can always do a list and then i can
specify minus minus format and then try
to get the information in a json format
or ml or minus minus format text
so you can always do a list you can do a
filter so there are different options
with your list and you can you can try
doing a help here and that basically
shows you what are the options
so for example if i do a help and it
shows me with list what are the things
you can do so you can give a name you
can give a regular expression you can
say in particular zone you can use a
minus filter so there are different
commands which are available and you can
always find all those options here as i
showed you earlier so now what we would
be interested in is basically going for
your compute instances i can always do a
ssh and i can create an instance
i can add and remove metadata right for
my instances
by giving a particular zone
by giving a particular region
and if you would want to do that now
here what we can do is we can basically
create an instance by just giving a name
to that particular instance and we can
then go back to our console and see what
has it done so i can say
here create so that's an option let's
see what does the create do so it says
okay you are giving a create option but
you would have to give a name so let's
say
let's call it e1 and that will be the
name of my instance and this one is an
easy command from your cloud shell which
basically creates an instance you see
the zone which has been set it is the
standard machine type it is not
preemptable it has an internal ip and it
has an external ip
now i have created an instance and here
i can just go back and then i can just
do a refresh on this page and that
already shows me the instance which i
have created and then you can use the
same method to connect to it using an
ssh so i have an instance created from
my cloud shell
and what i can do is i can basically
look into instances and see what are the
different options with instance so if we
did a create
right you have an option delete
we did a create you have an option
delete you can be then deleting the
instance from the command line or you
can use other options so you can do a
list you can do a stop
you can start so i can basically do a
stop and let's say even let's go ahead
and do a stop commands are pretty easy
here to remember or you can always use
the help option and now i'm trying to
stop the instance and then basically i
can go ahead and delete it so this is a
simple way where i created a instance
from the command line or from the
console which i showed earlier and
similarly you can be working with other
options
so now i've created stop the instance
let's do a listing to see
if my instance shows up it shows up
right and it says the status is
terminated so you have stopped it
it's in the terminated status and now
what i can do is i can go ahead and
delete it
so it says this will be lost are you
sure you would want to continue just say
yes
and that should take care of deleting
your instance
so this is a quick demo on creating your
instance we have already seen how you
can connect to these instances using ssh
now that we have created instances let's
also see how to use google cloud's
storage
service which can be used to load data
or upload data so for this we will have
to look into your google cloud storage
options and here you can look in cloud
storage so let's go back here on the top
which shows me different services which
we have here and let's look into storage
so this one shows me your storage option
now you can click on browser and that
basically shows me your storage browser
which shows me on the top you have
options for
creating a bucket now google cloud
storage allows you to store any kind of
data here
the easiest and the simplest way would
be by using cloud console although you
can again use cloud shell and in that
you can use your gsutil command
and gsutil basically has different
options
where you can be
using say for example i would want to
work on buckets so i can be using mb and
then i can use my command line option to
create buckets i can put in data there i
can browse it and i can access the data
from command line so let's create a
bucket here
let's click on this let's give it a name
so let's say my
data important that's the name
now i can click on continue straight
away i can look into all of these
options if i'm interested in
so you can basically be looking at your
monthly cost estimate in the beginning
now i can click on continue or you can
say choose where to store your data and
this one shows you different options so
you have region specific
so let's also give the bucket name with
all lower case that's what is required
yeah so coming back to the location type
you can choose multi region which
basically allows high availability so
your bucket or your storage option will
be accessible across regions
you can also give dual region and high
availability and low latency across two
regions i can also say region specific
so for our use case we can just give
region specific which can keep our cost
low but in business use cases you would
be going for multi region
now here you have location and i would
again go for say europe and let's choose
europe west 3 frankfurt
it is always a good practice that when
you create your instances when you
create your storage
or you use different services
try to have a geographical region chosen
and then you would try to put things or
your services within the particular
region within a particular zone unless
you would want to make it
accessible and available across regions
now i can then choose a default storage
class so when you say default storage
class there are different storage class
and each one is for a different use case
so you have standard which is best for
short term storage and frequently
accessed data you have near line so this
is basically best for backups and data
access less than once a month you can
also have cold lines so these are
basically like your cold storage or
freezing storage which you might have
heard generically as terms so you can
choose one of these storage classes
depending on what will be the use case
for this particular storage bucket so
let it be standard now how to control
access to objects so you can basically
say specify access to individual objects
by using object level permissions
now you can give permissions to the
bucket you can just say
uniform access to all objects in the
bucket by using only bucket level
permissions so you can choose that you
can also go into advanced settings and
here you can see different ways in which
you can have configuration setup now you
can also have a retention policy to
specify the minimum duration where that
this buckets object must be protected
from deletion and you can set a
retention policy will not get into all
that we will just first try creating a
bucket so just click on create and that
should create your bucket wherein i have
my bucket now i can click on overview to
see the details what is the region
which region it belongs what is the
storage class anytime you can always
click on edit bucket and make some
changes here you can look at the
permissions so bucket uses fine grained
access allowing you to specify access to
individual objects
and then you can basically look at who
has access to this so in my case
editors of the project they basically
are the bucket owners
owners of project viewers of the project
right and you can basically choose what
kind of access you need so for this
you can always go into cloud storage and
then you can decide what kind of access
you would want to give whether that's a
storage admin it's an object admin
object creator object viewer and so on
you can always look at storage legacy
and for any other services depending on
what apis you have enabled right you can
always control your permissions so right
now it is storage legacy bucket reader
and that's fine and this one is bucket
owner and then might be i was using some
other services like data proc which uses
cloud storage and that's why i have
given data proc service agent also so
these are some of the members you can
remove
you can view by specific members you can
view by roles so what are the different
roles which have access to this so it
says storage legacy bucket owner there
are two owners
based on this particular project so
these are auto controlled but then you
can add or remove machines you can
save storage cost by adding a life cycle
rule to delete objects after the
duration of current retention policy so
you can add different policies and you
can basically control your bucket now my
bucket is already created right so i can
go back and then i see my bucket is
already here i can click on this option
and you can anytime edit the bucket
permissions you can edit the labels the
default storage class you can just go
ahead and delete the bucket you can
export it to cloud pub sub so basically
if you would want to have the content
from this bucket being accessible in a
message queuing system you can go for
pub sub you can process with cloud
functions and you can scan with cloud
data loss prevention so there are
different options which are available we
can always select this bucket and delete
it now i can click on the bucket
and that basically shows me different
ways in which i can upload some data
here so i can just click on upload files
and here then i can choose some files so
for example i'll go in here
i'll go into data sets and i have
different data sets so for example let's
choose this one which is a csv file
and then i'm just uploading this to my
cloud storage right it's as simple as
this so you can drag and drop your files
or you can just upload your files and my
file is uploaded here now i can
basically edit permissions for this one
right so this is in the bucket so anyone
who has access to this bucket can
basically download this file it can they
can copy move or rename this you can
export it and you can look at the
permissions of this file so let's look
at edit permissions and it says
for this project whoever is the owner it
has access i've also given a specific
user my gmail id and i've given access
so at any point of time you can just say
add item and then you can start giving
different kind of accesses
so let's click on cancel here now my
data is already uploaded into this
particular bucket and that's a simple
usage of your cloud storage now what we
can also do is i can basically select
this and i can delete it i can also
create specific folders and then
basically
load data into it i can click on this
one i can just do a download and then i
can download it anywhere on my machine
so let's go to desktop and let's
download this file so we not only
uploaded some content in the bucket but
we also downloaded that in a different
location which will be accessible now
what i could have also done is i could
have created a folder here and i could
have specified
say for example immediate immediate data
okay and i'm clicking on this one so
that's my immediate data i can click on
this one and now
i can upload my data specifically to
this particular folder by using the same
mechanism you can just do upload file
let's choose air passengers
let's do a open and my file will be
uploaded
so you can
always choose what is the retention
expiry date for this one so as of now
there is nothing right but you can be
deleted objects can be deleted or
modified until they reach their minimum
duration you can control all of that you
can basically download it right you can
copy it and you can move it and rename
it so this is a simple example where i
created a particular bucket right now if
for example you click on this transfer
so it says cloud storage data transfer
products have moved you can now find
storage transfer service on-premise data
and transfer appliance in new data
transfer section right so you can always
go back
to cloud storage you can also look at
transfer options which are mainly when
you are using your on-premise service
and you would want to upload data in a
google cloud right so this is my bucket
here now i can go to cloud console and
here what i can do is if i would be
interested in working so i can just say
gsutil right and then we have
for example let's try a help okay and
that basically shows me my gsutil now
you can always go to quick start gsutil
tool and this is one more way wherein
basically you can do it from the command
line so working with buckets so you can
do a gsu till mb minus b and then on a
particular zone if you would be
interested in and then you can say g is
colon and give a name so my awesome
bucket this is how you will create a
bucket
which will show you it is creating a
bucket
and then basically you can upload an
image or some data from internet you can
just do a wget download the file and
then you can just do a gsutil copy
command and that basically will pick up
the file from your cloud shell location
put it in your bucket
once you have done that you can always
do a copy
right so here you are doing a copy from
your local machine that is your cloud
shell machine to your bucket and you can
do the reverse of that that is you can
do a copy and you can point your bucket
and the file and download it to your
desktops so you can just download that
using the command line
and you can copy the object to a folder
in the bucket so that is by creating a
particular folder
and you are pushing the file into a
particular bucket you can list the
contents of a bucket using ls and then
give your bucket name so gs colon so we
can just try this one to be simple and
rest you guys can try so here you can
just do a gsutil
you can do a ls
gs colon slash
and then i need to give my
bucket name so in my case the bucket
name was
my data important so let's try that so
let's say my data important and i'm
trying to list the bucket and the
content it has right and then you have a
folder and then you can look into the
folder and look into the files
so this is a simple quick option wherein
you can use your cloud shell you could
be using your google cloud sdk from your
local machine or you can be using cloud
console to create a bucket upload some
data on it download the data see if the
data is accessible and that basically
shows you the power of cloud storage
where you can easily upload any kind of
data now what we can also do is as you
are using a free account or even a paid
account unless and until you would want
to keep the bucket you can select it and
you can just go ahead and delete it so
this will basically ask you to key in
the bucket name and let's say my data
important you need to confirm your
bucket name click on confirm and you
could have done that using gsutil and a
delete command from the command line
that is from cloud cell so we have now
created a bucket we have uploaded some
data into it we saw how you can download
it or create a folder and upload some
specific data into it and also you can
do the same thing using gsutil tools
wherein you can list your bucket create
your buckets delete it create some
folders into it and do everything from
the command line so this is in simple
way you can use your gcp where either
you can spin up your machines or you can
use cloud storage to basically use a
storage or a easy to use instance on
google cloud platform welcome to this
tutorial about google cloud platform
and here
we will learn about cloud computing
what is cloud computing
what is gcp
that is your google cloud platform
what are the benefits of google cloud
platform and what are its different
services
a little bit about google's
infrastructure a comparison of different
cloud providers
such as google offering gcp that is
google's cloud platform amazon offering
amazon web services
and microsoft which offers azure we will
also learn about domino's pizza use case
and then have a quick demo on using some
of the services on gcp
before we begin let's understand why
cloud computing and it would be always
good to learn about cloud computing
based on a use case there are varied use
cases where
organizations are adopting or
moving their solutions or their
infrastructure into cloud or i can
simply say integrating with cloud now
here is one use case nina started a
company that relates to website
development
the challenges which nina was facing
were low memory space
whenever required for processing or for
any other kind of application related
work
high traffic to website that crashed it
and also less number of servers
now with these challenges she was then
referred to concept of cloud computing
and how that could benefit and help her
in solving her issues
most of her issues were solved
when she started using cloud computing
and with cloud computing she could
increase her memory
space as required that is on demand
control the load to the website that is
basically load balancing and handling
more requests on the website or request
per minute
buying
servers at a lower price that is scaling
up or down based on the requirement
when we talk about cloud computing
cloud computing is use of hardware and
software components which a cloud
provider offers as a service which can
be accessed over network
cloud computing is use of these
resources which could be either
dedicated resources or coming from a
pool of resources which cloud provider
offers
to deliver a service to
clients
users can access these different
services
applications files from any device
which can basically access internet
cloud computing allows automatic
software integration
it allows backing up and restoring of
data
it basically offers unlimited storage
memory or computation capacity
it gives access to reliable sources
which usually the cloud provider
themselves are using for their use case
and it is a cost efficient model which
helps organizations to quickly
integrate
or
basically modernize their infrastructure
cloud computing is usually used
with id or
within id space
wherein
there are five traits
if there is a requirement of resources
as the business dynamically changes or
grows
so for this cloud computing offers
on-demand self-service
so
users could be using on-demand computing
resources
or memory resources storage network and
so on provided by cloud provider and
also do a self-service
all this is possible using a simple
interface
and users can be using processing power
storage network as they need and pay as
they go so there is least or no human
intervention required
when it comes to
projects which might need
scalable network access
cloud computing offers broad network
access that is accessing resources over
network across geographical regions or
what we call as availability zones
which might be multiple sites within a
particular geographical region
cloud providers also have what we call
as a resource pooling so this basically
provides a huge pool of resources which
are shared and can be accessed by
customers at a lower cost now there
might be customers which are interested
in not sharing the resources and would
be interested in dedicated resources and
in this case cloud provider also have
sold tenant offerings which help such
customers
if an it business or any other business
needs rapid elasticity
then cloud providers also have resources
which are offered which are elastic you
can get more resources rapidly as needed
and thus you can scale up and down think
of a gaming company which would be
interested in launching a new game
and they would have predicted a certain
number of users which would get on to
the portal playing the game and what
happens if the request per minute or if
the number of users who are joining in
might increase
now in this case organization would want
an underlying solution which handles
this dynamism scales
as
needed on demand and once the demand is
done scales down
this is possible using a cloud computing
solution
cloud computing solutions also include
measured services that is pay as you go
model for the usage or for the
reservations which a user or
organization would have made
for resources offered by cloud computing
so when we talk about cloud computing
one of the question which always arises
is
why is this model so compelling why is
this so interesting for organizations or
users who would want to use one or many
services from cloud computing so first
wave of trend which brought storage
cloud computing was what we call as colo
that is co-location
i.t shops
that have been
using
or
managing huge amount of data from
decades
basically wanted to build
their infrastructures to handle their
business needs
now
instead of building costlier data
centers
they would rent space or share
facilities and this was being done by
organizations even in past
thus they would free up the capital for
other use cases
now this was more of user configured
managed and maintained by them
later organizations started thinking of
virtualization
so that was again user configured
but provider managed and maintained
so components of a virtualized data
center
matched that of a physical data center
and
organizations would have virtual devices
separately managed from underlying
devices
then later came container based
architectures or basically
automated services
so within google services are
automatically provisioned and configured
letting your infrastructure scale
on demand there are various reasons why
an organization would think of
integrating with cloud or benefiting
by using cloud and thus
instantaneously
reaping the benefits of modernizing
their infrastructure
now few famous cloud providers are here
so you have
amazon which offers amazon web services
and a huge list of services
which come in with this
you have microsoft's azure you have
oracle's cloud you have saps cloud
solutions gcp which is offered by google
salesforce and so on there are many
other small players which are also
providing different services which are
cloud-based or
organizations which are partnering with
these main cloud providers thus offering
cloud services to their customers
when we talk about why google cloud
platform there are various reasons why
someone would choose google cloud
platform
gcp has better pricing compared to its
competitors
when it comes to speed and performance
it is very fast and increases the
performance of the project
live migration of apps and there are
huge number of solutions which i will
show you further in further screens
which help an organization to adopt to a
cloud platform an integrated with cloud
platform or even completely migrate into
a cloud platform
none of google's competitors provide
live migration of apps
when we talk about big data ai machine
learning kind of solutions gcp provides
a lot of innovative solutions
in comparison to other cloud providers
such as aws azure and so on
so what is google cloud platform it has
a set of cloud computing services
provided by google that runs on the same
infrastructure that google uses
to and for its end user products like
youtube gmail and so on
let's learn about benefits of google
cloud platform
such as high productivity
working from anywhere
quick collaboration high security
fewer data stored on vulnerable devices
reliable resources which can be used
across organization across geographical
regions across countries
very flexible which allows organizations
to scale up and down
as
the demand rises or as the demand
declines
and cost effective solutions for various
use cases these are some of the benefits
and
if we look into different services which
google cloud platform offers
we could look into detailed benefits
which each service offers in a different
use case which basically helps
organizations
working in different domains handling
different kind of small mid or larger
businesses and with different business
goals
when we talk about google cloud platform
services here is a list of services or i
could say high level domains or
categories of services so you have
compute related services you have
storage and database you have networking
big data
developer tools identity and security
management
internet of things cloud ai management
tools and also data transfer solutions
when we talk about google's
infrastructure google has one of the
most powerful infrastructure in the
world
the infrastructure is available in two
levels the physical and the abstract
layers you have physical infrastructure
and then you have the abstract
infrastructure
physical infrastructure consists of data
centers extensive development of high
efficiency back-end data centers
you have a very strong backbone network
which is used by google itself and also
offered
as services to customers via gcp
platform services so
you have global meshed redundant
backbone network
points of presence
when we talk about google
it has 110 plus edge points of presence
in more than 200 countries and when we
talk about edge caching
edge caching platform at periphery of
their network
so this is
what defines the physical infrastructure
of google now there is much more to it
rather than just these four points when
we talk about abstract infrastructure
that is divided in global
regions and zones
when we talk about
zone a zone is roughly equivalent to a
data center
and a single point of failure so you
could have your compute engine
which is within a zone or you could say
compute engine is a zonal resource
you have regions which are geographical
areas which contain multiple zones
so you could have a region for u.s
central or
europe central europe west and so on and
within a region you would have one or
multiple zones and zones basically would
allow high availability of resources
so you have cloud load balancer is an
example which is regional resource then
you have global resources and they are
available and shared across the planet
so you have various global resources
such as network
which could be even your ip addresses
and so on
now let's do a quick comparison of aws
west seoul west
gcp and let's look at what each cloud
provider offers
later we will also look into different
services
in detail when it comes to google cloud
platform
what each service does
what you can benefit from which service
should you use in what case we will
learn about those in later slides
if i compare
your different cloud providers
when we talk about amazon
and its cloud offerings that is amazon
web services or aws as we will know it
amazon web services has 69 availability
zones within 22 geographical locations
and soon it will have 12 more in future
so this number keeps growing based on
the spread of the services which a
particular cloud provider offers
here we are talking about availability
zone specific information when we talk
about microsoft's azure it has 54
regions worldwide and is available in
140 countries across the globe
when we talk about google cloud gold
cloud platform is available in 200 plus
countries across the globe
when we talk about virtual servers
amazon's ec2 that is elastic compute
cloud it is a web service which
basically helps to resize your compute
capacity where you can run your
application programs on a virtual
machine so using ec2 service you could
launch
virtual instances that would have any
distribution of linux windows you could
have different specifications when it
comes to ram or cpu cores or disk you
could also decide on
what kind of storage a particular
instance should use
whether the storage should be local to
the instance or whether that should be a
elastic file system or even an object
storage
when it comes to azure or microsoft's
offering as your virtual machine
that is infrastructure as a service
gives a user the ability to
deploy and manage a virtual environment
inside a virtual network on the cloud
and this virtual network on the cloud
would be managed by cloud provider
google cloud or the offerings from
google cloud platform that is gcp vm
instances enables users to build deploy
and manage virtual machines in order to
run different kind of workloads on the
cloud now when we talk about compute
engine here it would be good to discuss
a little bit more about compute engine
and what are the different options which
google cloud offers so when you talk
about your compute engine
you have
scalable high performance virtual
machines compute engine delivers
configurable virtual machines which run
in google's data center with access to
high performance networking
infrastructure and block storage and you
could select vms for your needs that
could be general purpose or workload
optimized and when we talk about
workload optimized you have predefined
machines or you have custom machine
sizes
you can integrate compute with other
google cloud services such as ai or ml
and
go for your data analytics
you have when we talk about your gcp vm
instances just to expand on that you
have general purpose
instances which we call as n2
which provide a balance between price
and performance and they are well suited
for most workloads including line of
business applications web servers and
databases
google cloud also offers compute
optimized instances
which we call as c2 instances
which offer consistent high-end virtual
cpu performance
which are good for aaa gaming eda
hbc and other applications
now when we talk about compute optimize
your general purpose how would we leave
memory optimized instances those are m2
machines which google offers so these
offer highest amount of memory these vms
are well suited for in-memory databases
such as sap hana real-time analytics and
in-memory caches
so if i would summarize this when we
talk about
different instances aws
also offers different kind of instances
which are memory or compute
or
disk optimized you have general purpose
and each category of machines has a
different pricing model you can always
go to an aws website look for the
pricing models and that will give you an
idea of on-demand instances or dedicated
instances reserved instances and so on
similarly if you talk about google cloud
google cloud also has instances with
various options which become the key
features of why customers would choose
google cloud platform such as live
migration for vms
so compute engine
within your gcp can live migrate between
host systems and when i say live migrate
it basically means without rebooting
which keeps your application running
even when the underlying host systems
require maintenance you also have
preemptable
virtual machines wherein you can run bad
jobs and fault tolerant workloads on
pre-emptible vms to reduce your virtual
cpu and memory cost by up to 80 percent
while getting the same performance so
these are your preemptive or preemptable
virtual machines the only demand it is
these can give you a really cost
efficient
resource usage however can be taken off
the shelf anytime and that's why we call
them preemptable virtual machines you
also have sole tenant nodes which are
physical compute engine servers
dedicated explicitly or exclusively for
users use case
and
when we talk about sole tenant nodes
these are usually good when you are
dealing with or when you are working
with your applications which we call as
bring your own license applications so
sole tenant nodes give you access to
same machine types and virtual machine
config options as regular compute
instances
so there are different options which
google cloud offers when it comes to
these instances which we are talking
about and it takes care of different use
cases in comparison to other cloud
providers which are also offering these
services such as you can have predefined
machine types you can have custom
machine types preemptable vms as i said
live migration of vms
you can use persistent disks which could
give you durable high performance block
storage you have local ssds you also
have gpu accelerators which can be added
to accelerate computational
intensive workloads such as machine
learning simulation medical analysis and
so on and you have features such as
global load balancing which
makes google cloud a unique
choice when we talk about platform as a
service amazon has
platform as a service offering which we
call as elastic bean stock
among one of its services it's an
orchestration service for deploying
applications and helping in maintaining
these applications
azure cloud service
provides a platform to write the user
application code without worrying about
the hardware resources
google app engine is a service used by
developers for building and hosting
applications on google's data centers
when we talk about server-less computing
so amazon's aws lambda is a serverless
compute service it is used to execute
backend code and scales automatically
when required when we talk about azure
you have something called as functions
which allow users
to build applications using serverless
symbol functions with a programming
language of their choice
when we talk about google cloud
gcp has cloud functions which is easiest
way to run your code in the cloud and it
is highly available and fault tolerant
so in these days when we are talking
about microservices architecture which
organizations are preferring when we are
talking about organizations which can
scale which can dynamically
change their underlying architecture
organizations would be interested in
server less computing where they do not
have to have a infrastructure set up
planned in advance before going for
their use case and this is where
monolithic applications
are really not a preferred choice
a lot of organizations are decomposing
their applications into microservices
based on
business capability or decomposing based
on sub domains we can learn about
microservices architecture later but
just to know that serverless computing
which
basically helps any organization if for
example if you have a web application
that receives
non-linear traffic and you cannot keep
an eye on your server always
it would be good to have someone to auto
scale your application serverless is
basically a computing model where cloud
service provider
is responsible for managing the piece of
code without the developer having to
bother about infrastructure setup
management maintenance and so on
now when we talk about applications
being serverless or benefiting from
serverless computing
one of the key things would be zero
administration so deploying application
without any provisioning and management
auto scaling capability that is let the
service provider worry about
scaling the application up and down
you have paper use model which any
customer would want to benefit from
that is pay only for the resources that
you have used or that you are continuing
to use
right
shorten the time between
idea implementation and employment and
this is something which any organization
would want that
you would want
a faster
bring to the market solution timeline in
comparison to getting entangled with
deployment management and maintenance of
your underlying infrastructure when your
applications are facing a high demand
so when we talk about serverless
it is a function as a service
because each part of your application is
divided as functions and can be hosted
over multiple service providers
you have serverless apps which are
usually divided as separate units or
functions based on functionalities or
domains and so on so serverless
computing is gaining quite popularity
these days
in comparison to the traditional
three-tier architecture
where you had a presentation layer you
had an application layer you had a
database layer now that kind of
infrastructure is not really preferred
in today's modern times when
organizations are working on different
kind of newer applications
when we talk about object storage amazon
has simple storage service that is s3 it
provides object storage which is built
for storing and recovering information
or data from anywhere over the internet
azure comes up with blob storage that is
binary large objects storage offers
large amount of storage and scalability
it stores the object in the tiers and
depending on how often the data is being
accessed now same thing applies to even
s3
which is from amazon so s3 also has
different kind of storage classes which
can be selected when a user or
organization intends to use a storage
service and when i speak about storage
classes it basically means having a
frequent access storage or a infrequent
access storage or what we call as
just an archival solution
google cloud has cloud storage and it
provides unified object storage for live
or archive data the service is used to
store and access data on gcp
infrastructure
when it comes to advantages
amazon web services
has enterprise friendly services easy
access to resources
increase in speed and agility and that
too on demand and takes care of your
security and reliability of resources
which are offered
when it comes to azure it has better
development operations strong security
profile provides a lot of cost effective
solutions and
operation execution friendly
when we talk about google cloud one of
the key features here is better pricing
than competitors
live migration of virtual machines which
really interests a lot of organizations
would want to modernize their
infrastructure without having any kind
of disruption in their existing services
improved performance redundant backups
and so on
when it comes to disadvantages
in aws you have limitations when it
comes to ec2 service well there are
different options in the kind of
machines which you can choose which you
can work on
you have a technical support fee
which is incurred network connectivity
and then also downtime which might be in
case when you're migrating azure it has
different code base for cloud and
premise platform as a service ecosystem
is not really as efficient as
infrastructure as a service
poor management of gui and tools
integrated backup
when we talk about google cloud support
fee is quite hefty it depends on what
kind of solution or support you would or
organization would be interested in it
has a complex pricing schema
although it has different use cases for
which
any user or any organization can benefit
from
downloading data from google cloud
services is an expensive option storage
might not be however uploading data or
downloading data would be an expensive
option
when we talk about domino's pizza use
case now while we were discussing about
these features i would really want to
spend more time in
discussing each of these features or
services in detail such as you have
compute engine
you have storage
you have big table you have data proc
and so on so there are huge list of
services now before we get into
your domino's bizarre use case let me
show you this page on google cloud where
you can
look at different services so if you go
to cloud.google.com and if you look at
get started option under dock so here
you can find build solutions look at
different use cases learn from basics
of what is your google cloud what are
cloud basics
then you can look at different cloud
products so here you have products in
different categories such as ai and
machine learning api management compute
containers data analytics databases
developer tools and so on and you can
always click on
any one of these to look into different
solutions which are being offered what
are the different use cases what are the
best practices when it comes to
migrating vms to compute engine
or operating containers or building
containers and so on you can always look
at featured products and that gives you
a quick snapshot of what are the
different products such as you have
compute engine you have cloud run
bigquery which is a data warehouse you
have cloud sql which is a managed mysql
or postgres you have cloud storage to
basically push in any kind of data there
you have security key enforcement ai and
machine learning and so on so you have
different feature products now if you
scroll down
to the lower end of this page
you can again look at
different solutions and that would be
really interesting to read and learn
from so you have infrastructure
modernization you have application
modernization you have data management
and so on so if i look at
infrastructure modernization
you could basically look at the
solutions which google cloud offers
and what it does when it comes to
having your
infrastructure modernized or benefiting
by
integrating with cloud and having
immediate benefits of infrastructure
modernization you can look at different
use cases what they are doing
how google cloud really helps when it
comes to
migrating the workloads to a cloud
and how your different cloud solutions
such as vm migration you have sap on
google cloud vmware as a service and so
on and you could learn from these
different solutions which are offered
you can also look at application
modernization so not only infrastructure
modernization but organizations would
also be interested in re-looking at
their applications we looking at how
these applications
could be moved from monolithic to
microservices architecture or how
applications can benefit from
modernization
and cloud computing offerings so you
have again different use cases here
which talks about different ways in
which google cloud can help how you can
modernize your applications how you can
use different solutions which google
cloud is offering now when you talk
about cloud computing services you can
always go into
cloud.google.com
if you have created a free account then
you can just log in and every user by
default gets a 300 free credit
so when they can try out different
products where they can use different
services so here if i click on console
where i'm already logged in with my
gmail account or my google cloud account
wherein i have
300 free credit out of which some is
being used you have a google cloud
console and here from the hamburger menu
you can click and you can look at
different services within different
domains so you have compute domain which
has different services such as app you
have compute engine and that basically
allows you to use your vm instances
which we were talking about previous
slides
different instance groups create your
templates use soul tenant nodes
create snapshots or backup of your data
use different zones you can go for
kubernetes which is containerized based
engine you have cloud functions
you have cloud run
and then you have storage related
different options such as big table you
have data store fire store file store
storage and so on and for each of these
services you can read about from the
google's documentation or anyways i will
be explaining that later
you can also look at networking related
operation related and other tools which
are offered by google cloud so these are
huge list of services which google cloud
platform offers in different ways for
different use cases
now let's look at this domino's pizza
use case
and see what it helps us learn about so
you can always access this page by going
to this
link which talks about customers and
then which shows you different use cases
so domino's increasing monthly revenue
by six percent with google analytics
premium google tag manager and google
bigquery
so this is
basically when
domino's started using gcp and what was
the result of that
now let's look further into this
so we all know
that domino is most popular pizza
delivery
chain operating across the globe but how
was that possible let's take a look so
the challenges were they wanted to
integrate marketing measurement across
various devices
connecting crm and digital data to
create a clear view of customer behavior
to make cross-channel marketing
performance analysis easy and efficient
now for these challenges which dominos
was facing the solution was using google
analytics premium
google tag manager and bigquery which
were used to integrate digital data
sources and crm data
reporting was made easier and more
efficient by implementing google
analytics premium because it had the
ability to access a single google
analytics account
to evaluate web and app performance
by using the new google tag manager
implementation dominance were able to
act fast
they were able to connect crm data with
digital analytics which basically
provided domino with greater visibility
on customer behavior what was the result
there was an immediate six percent
increase in monthly revenue
eighty percent of costs and ad serving
and operations were saved
increases
agility with streamlined tag management
they obtained easy access to powerful
reporting and customized dashboards now
that was just one simple use case before
we go on to hands-on we can also talk a
little bit
back
about these services which google cloud
offers
as we discussed and some of these
services which can really make you think
why not google cloud platform so when we
talk about your different cloud platform
services
let's learn about some of these services
in brief in what each service is what it
does and how it can help us in handling
our use cases or working with different
products so let's learn briefly about
different services which google cloud
platform offers now one of the domains
is compute and then let's look at the
compute services which gcp offers now
here i can log into the console and this
hamburger menu on the top left corner i
can click on this one and go into the
compute engine section so this is the
compute domain which has app engine
kubernetes engine cloud functions and
cloud run so these are your different
services which are offered within the
compute domain and here we can get into
compute engine by clicking on this one
and then basically going to vm instances
so before we see how we can use this
compute engine let's understand about
some of the features of compute engine
which basically offers scalable high
performance virtual machines which are
configurable and which runs in google's
data center with access to high
performance networking infrastructure
and block storage so from here you can
select vm for your needs for your
general purpose or workload optimized
predefined or custom machines now here
you can integrate compute with other
google cloud services such as ai ml and
other data analytics services you have
different machines which are offered
here such as general purpose
which provide a balance between price
and performance which are well suited
for most workloads including line of
business applications web services and
databases you also have compute
optimized machines which offer
consistent high end virtual cpu core
performance and which are mainly good
for gaming eda high process computing
and other such applications apart from
general purpose compute optimized you
also have memory optimized machines
which offer highest amount of memory and
these vms are basically well suited for
in-memory databases such as sap hana
real-time analytics and in-memory cache
now we can see these options here you
can click on vm instances while you're
logged in into your google cloud console
here you can even create an instance
template which can be used to spin up
instances for example if i click on new
vm instance from a template there are
some templates which i have already
created for my usage now here i can
basically use one of these templates or
what i can do is i can go back i can go
into instance templates and this
basically allows me to create a template
so you can click on create instance
template which basically allows you to
create templates which can be used to
spin up different instances we can give
a name to the template for example we
can say template
instance now here i can choose machine
configurations and this is where you
have different options so you have
general purpose as i mentioned which
provide a balance between price and
performance you have memory optimized
which are large memory machine types for
memory intensive workloads you also have
compute optimized which basically give
you high performance machine types for
compute intensive workloads so you can
choose any machine configuration which
is available here based on your
requirements now if you click on general
purpose that has different options here
so you look into the series where you
have n1 series you have e2 which are cpu
platform selection based on availability
you have n2 and n2d so let's just have
n1 selected now you also have here which
talks about machine types and here we
can choose the configuration which we
are interested in depending on the
applications which will run within the
machines we can choose a machine so by
default it shows one virtual cpu core
and 3.5 gigabyte of memory or ram you
could choose a higher end machine so as
of now i'll just say n1 standard
now that basically allows me to choose
these machines so there are different
features which your compute offers such
as you have live migration for vms you
have preemptable virtual machines you
have sold tenant nodes and all those
options can be seen here now in this
machine for my boot disk i can select a
distribution which i would be interested
in for example i could be going for
public images and i can choose for
example ubuntu and then i can choose a
version so it shows me 16.04
and you also have latest versions such
as ubuntu 20. you can choose one of
these and here it asks you to choose the
boot disk type so that could be standard
persistent disk which is hdds which are
low in performance and
you can say low in cost in comparison to
ssds so ssds give you better performance
but then they are little expensive than
using standard persistent disk we can
choose this and we can give a disk size
for example 20 gigabyte and i can click
on select before clicking on select i
can click on custom images and that
shows me if you have any other images
created in your project you could use
those you could also learn about images
by clicking on this link so we'll click
on public images we have chosen this
distribution let's do a select and now
here you have identity and api access
management so let this by default you
can say allow default access and what
you need is depending on the services we
can choose it allows http and https
traffic now we would also need some way
to connect to these machines so when you
set up an instance by default you can do
ssh into it using the google cloud
console or from cloud shell you can also
give a private and a public key so here
you have the option where you can give
all these details so when it comes to
management it tells you what would you
want to go for reservations and you can
say automatically use created
reservation you could also say no you
would not want to use a reservation you
can also set up or provide a startup
script which you would want to give
whenever your machines come up and here
you have the options of preemptability
so compute offers preemptable virtual
machines so that is mainly when you
would want to run bad jobs and fault
tolerant workloads on these machines and
you can benefit with a reduced cost for
your virtual cpu and memory by 80
so these are virtual machines which
would be lasting less than 24 hours now
by default this is off and it purely
depends on your workload what you would
want to run on these instances i could
just go ahead and select preemptable
being on that and use this feature of
compute you also have on host
maintenance which talks about what would
be happening with this compute engine
instance so when compute engine performs
periodic infrastructure maintenance it
can migrate your vm instances to other
hardware and this is one of the features
which compute engine offers which we
call as live migration for vms here your
compute engine can live migrate between
host systems that is the underlying
systems on which these vm instances are
based on without rebooting which will
keep your application running even when
host system require maintenance and here
it says migrate vm instance recommended
and let that be as it is you can also
say that if there is a maintenance
happening you can terminate the vm
instance now it also talks about
automatic restart which is on which
basically means compute engine can
automatically restart vm instances if
they are terminated from non-user
initiated reasons so these are all the
settings which are available in
management and it also tells us the
different features which we have there
is also a feature called sold tenancy
which basically means sold tenant sold
tenant nodes which can be chosen so you
can have physical compute engine servers
dedicated exclusively for your use and
this is usually good when you are
talking about bring your own license
applications so sole tenant nodes give
you access to same machine types and vm
configuration options as regular compute
instances however these might be a
little expensive we can choose this one
we can also look into networking which
basically shows the default setup which
goes for auto subnet you can also choose
a particular ip if that is required but
that would cost more you can click on
disks which talk about what do you want
to do with the boot disk when the
instance is deleted what is the
encryption mechanism you would want to
use and here finally you have security
so basically as i said you can ssh into
instance using the cloud console option
and you can also provide a public ssh
key so one way of doing that if you
intend to use an external ssh client
such as putty to connect you can create
a key
so for example i can go into puttygen
and here i can say generate just move my
cursor over here and that will create a
key i can give a name to this one so
i'll say sdu will be username i'll give
a simple password which i will use to
login to this machine and then i can
save this private key which will get
saved so let's say hdu new key and this
gets saved in a dot ppk file which is
usually used when you use an external
ssh client to connect so save this one
and that saves a ppk file on your
desktop what you can also do is you can
copy this public key content from here
and this is what we would want to give
in our instance here so so that the
public key gets stored on the instance
and private key is what we will use to
connect so once i paste it here it
resolves the name to hdu and we have
given the public key now in certain
cases you may want to use a software
which uses ssh to connect to the machine
and that software might not be such as
your putty so in that case you may want
a pem file or a private key which is
saved as a dot pem file so you can also
do that by going to conversions and do
export open ssh key and then save it so
i'll say hdu new key but then this one
will be saved as a pem file on my
machine so you have ppk file which
allows you to use putty to connect to
the instance you have a pem in case a
software needs directly ssh to these
machines you also have the public key
which we have already provided in the
machine now once this is done i can
close puttygen i can go back to this
page where i'm creating an instance
template and then i can just click on
create so this has created an instance
template which i can use to spin up my
instances any number of instances using
the same template only thing which i
would have to do is change the region
where i would want the instance to run
so now that we have created instance and
that's my this one the third option i
can go back to vm instances now i can
click on create and here i can either
create an instance from scratch by
giving all the details again or i can
just use my template so i can click on
new vm instance from a template choose
my template click on continue and once
this is done i can give my instance name
so let's say c1 i can choose the region
so i will choose frankfurt and then rest
everything is auto populated based on
the template what you have given and you
click on create now this basically
allows you to spin up an instance and
you can create any number of instances
using your template you could have
already created a new instance right
from scratch now once the instance is
created this has a public ip and a
private ip private ip will not change
unless you would want to set up a new
machine but public ip will change every
time you stop and start the machine now
this is what we need to connect to this
machine i can also do a ssh from here by
doing this in open in a browser window
let's click on this so this is an
internal way of connecting to your
instance using ssh let's wait because it
would be transferring the ssh keys to
the vm it establishes a connection and i
am connected to my machine what we can
easily do is to confirm if we are in the
right machine we can just do a ls
to look at the file system what we can
also do is we can basically log in as
root by doing a sudo su and that allows
you to get into the machine as root and
from here i can switch to hdu user which
will have a dot ssh directory in home
and that basically has authorized keys
and if we would want to see if this one
contains my public key i can just do a
cat dot ssh and then look into
authorized keys and this shows me the
public key which we had initially added
to our instance so this confirms that we
are logged into the machine which we
created now i can close this
and what i can also do is i can copy
this public ip so let's do a copy to
clipboard now go to putty and here i
will say hostname where i'll say hdu
give my public key i'll click on ssh and
in ssh i'll go to authentication now
here we need to give our ppk file so the
ppk file was sdu new key select this one
come back here come to the session give
it a name for example c1 save it and
then you can just say open and say yes
and you are logged in to your machine
now once you are logged in you can
always do a minus ssh and that shows you
the file so this is how you have just
used the compute engine to spin up an
instance but we used a template which
basically allowed me to create this
instance and then i can connect to this
instance and then i can start working on
this so when we talk about features of
compute engine it has predefined machine
types as we saw so compute engine offers
different predefined virtual machines
and this they have configurations for
every need from small general purpose
instances to large memory optimized
instances with up to 11.5 terabytes of
ram
you can have fast compute instances
optimized up to 60 virtual cpu cores
you also have custom machine types so
you can create a vm that best fits your
workload and by tailoring a custom
machine type to your specific need you
can realize significant savings there
are preemptable vms which we saw there
is also a facility which allows you to
take the benefit of live migration for
vms you have durable high performance
block storage for virtual machine
instances in the form of persistent
disks where data is stored redundantly
for integrity flexibility and to resize
storage without interruption and you
could be choosing hdds or sdds for your
instances
now you also have option such as gpu
accelerators so for example if i just
click on create instance and i can look
into that so here let the instance name
be instance 1 and what i would be
interested in looking at this one which
says cpu platform and gpu so cpu
platform configuration is permanent you
can also do add gpu so gpus can be added
to accelerate computationally intensive
workloads like machine learning
simulation medical analysis and virtual
workstation applications so you can add
and remove gpus to a vm when your
workload changes and pay for gpu only
while using so these are some of the
features which basically compute engine
offers and we already know that google
bills in second level increments so we
only pay for the compute time now there
are different savings which are possible
so you have commitment savings which
basically means you can save up to 57
without upfront cost per instance type
lock-in
you have container support so you can
basically run manage and orchestrate
docker containers or compute engine
instances so here when we are setting up
our instances there is an option which
basically allows you to use or deploy
docker images now that can be done you
can also benefit from sustained use
savings that is sustained use discounts
which are automatic discounts for
running compute engine resources for
significant portion of the billing month
you can create a reservation for vm
instance in a specific zone which is
basically seen under your management
section here and you can ensure your
project has resources for future
increases in demand and if no longer
needed delete the reservation so these
are some of the features of compute
engine what we have done is we have
created compute engine using the console
now you can go back you can also do that
using cloud shell and you can click on
this one which activates cloud shell you
could also have the cloud sdk support on
setup on your machine which can be used
now i can just open this in a new window
and from here i can start giving
commands if i would be interested in
setting up an instance from my command
line so here you have different options
now to begin with you can just do a g
cloud and just hit enter and that will
show you different options which are
available which can be used so you have
g cloud compute here which shows
an option to create and manipulate
compute engine resources now i can just
do a queue to quit i can do g cloud
compute and that basically will again
show me different options which are
available if you would be interested in
setting up instances from the command
line so here i can say g cloud compute
and then go for
instances and if you do not know the
commands you can just hit enter that
will show you all the different options
which we have so here we have different
options such as list or create or start
or update for example i can just do a
list here to see what instances i have
and the instance which we just created
shows up here it says that status is
running i can just stop this instance i
can delete this instance i can even
create an instance by using a create
command here and you can just do a
create help which will show you what are
the different options you can give so it
says instance name
is what you need you can choose an
accelerator you can choose the boot disk
and various other options so i can just
say create and then i can give a name
for example c2 and once i click on this
one it says did you mean europe west 4
zone so it is asking me for the region
and the zone and i can say yes and these
settings are coming from my default
profile i can always change those by
changing the metadata so now we have
created an instance it says running if
we do a list again to see we see two
instances created one was in europe west
three one was only europius west four
both of them have internal and external
ips
now you can do a
describe to look at the different
options here so gcloud basically allows
you different commands which you can use
to work with your instance to create
instances to change the metadata if you
would want to change the region if you
would want to add a startup script all
those options are possible from the
command line which we can learn in
detail in later sessions so this is your
compute engine as a service now that we
have learnt about the compute domain and
g
compute services which is offered by gcp
let's also learn about storage and
databases that's again within the
storage domain and the services which
are offered by google cloud platform now
you can go back to console and here you
can click on this one and here you can
just scroll down to see what are the
different options in storage so you have
options such as big table you have data
store firestore file store you have sql
based services you have storage which is
object storage and then you have other
options which are available so google
cloud platform offers different storage
based services out of which storage
which is your object storage is quite
popular one click on storage and that
basically shows you an option which
talks about storage
browser so this is your google cloud's
object storage
so when we talk about object storage it
is basically a storage where you could
store any kind of data and when we talk
about object storage it is a bunch of
bytes which we address
wherein every object will have a unique
key these unique keys are in the form of
url which allows you to access the
object so cloud storage is comprised of
what we call as buckets which are used
to store and hold your storage objects
the storage objects are immutable and
every change creates a new version now
you can also have control access via iam
that is identity access management or
via access control list so there is also
an option called object versioning which
basically says if it is on every time
you try to store the same object a new
version of the object would be created
otherwise newer option will override old
one as we cannot archive the old version
so let's see how we work with this
object storage so here you can click on
create bucket
now once you click on create bucket it
needs a name so let's say test bucket
and here
i can just give say number one so that
says this is the name of my bucket now i
can directly click on continue or it
would be good to look at different
options which are available here
so
when you click on choose where to store
your data
so it already gives me an option it says
the bucket name is already taken so let
me give it a unique name so let's say
test buck and let's call it
aua so that should be unique now here it
says choose where to store your data
so this one gives you location type so
you can have region specific buckets
which give you lowest latency that is
fastest response time within a single
region however it does not make your
storage highly available you can make a
dual region which is basically allowing
your bucket or storage to be accessible
across regions you can also make it
multi-region which is highest
availability offered as of now we can
choose region specific and now it asks
you to choose a location now as
always i will choose
frankfurt
now i can click on continue and rest all
the rest let all the storage options be
default or you can click on a default
storage class now that tells you
based on your storage class there are
variant costs when it comes to storing
retrieving or doing any kind of
operations so you have a standard
option which says best for short-term
storage and frequently accessed data you
can also go for cold storage such as
near line which is best for backups and
data access less than once a month you
can go for freezing storage such as cold
line best for disaster recovery and data
accessed
less than once a quarter or you can go
for archiving where the data is accessed
less than once a year let's go for
standard as of now and now you can
choose how to control access to objects
so you have fine grained or uniform let
it be fine grained wherein you can give
additional permissions
at bucket level using iam or object
level permissions using access control
list
in advance settings you can choose the
encryption and you can also choose a
retention policy so a retention policy
to specify the minimum duration that
this buckets objects must be protected
from deletion or modification after they
are uploaded
you can always learn about this more by
clicking here now once i have chosen all
the relevant options i can click on
create and that basically will create a
bucket by the name i have given i can
click on overview to basically see
brief details about my bucket such as
region what is the default storage class
and it also shows you the link url which
can be used to access your bucket it
also gives you the link for gsutil now
gsutil is a command which can be used in
your cloud shell to basically work with
your buckets you can click on
permissions to basically see what kind
of permissions are already in place and
you can then make changes you can
basically add members you can view by
different roles so for example here by
default it shows
other services such as data proc or your
bucket owner or bucket reader related
permissions which have been already
granted now once i have looked at my
bucket i can start using it i can drag
and drop and push in files here so as of
now there are no live objects in my
object storage that is in my bucket what
i can do is i can click on upload files
and then i can choose a location from my
machine for example i'll go into data
sets and what i can do is i can choose
some of the files here
in any format let's choose csv or text
and just to open so this one will
basically upload my data sets here now
once i've uploaded the files i can
basically close this one i can look into
options here which says edit permissions
and edit metadata if you would want to
download it if you would want to copy
move or rename it if you would want to
export to a different service called
cloud pub sub which is publish
subscribing messaging system you can
scan the data now you can click on a
particular file and that basically shows
you the url which basically allows you
to access this file you can try copying
this you can click on download and
download this file you can even try
accessing this from public and that
basically shows you the content of this
file based on the permissions so this is
basically your object storage which is
one of the service which is offered what
you can also do is you can create
folders and within folders you can then
upload your data so this is your google
cloud
storage option which is for your
object storage that is you can add
different items you can give different
permissions and you can use this google
cloud platforms storage service offering
now you also have other options such as
big table and we can go into that by
clicking here and click on big table so
big table is one of the service which
kickstarted nosql databases today in
market we see different nosql databases
such as cassandra hbase mongodb
couchdb
neo4j and many others so you can
basically use
bigtable which was the pioneer when it
comes to your no sequel databases or not
only sql databases so the problem
initially faced by google was that
the web indexes behind search engine
were taking too long to build so company
wanted to build database that would
provide real-time access to petabytes of
data and that's where bigtable began so
big table powers different other google
services such as gmail google maps and
other services and in 2015
it was launched as a service for
customers so when it comes to
scalability with use of bigtable you can
increase your machine count without any
downtime and you can handle admin tasks
like upgrades restarts and so on which
are basically taken care by the cloud
provider data present in cloud bigtable
is encrypted and you can use im roles to
specify access so data written to or
from big table is through data service
layers such as managed virtual machines
hbase rest servers java services hbase
client and so on here if i would want to
use big table i can click on create
instance and that basically tells me
cloud bigtable instance is a container
for your clusters now here you can give
an instance name so for example
i will say aua and then say for example
test and let's say big table so that
will be the name of instance this will
be permanent you can choose the storage
type again you can go for lower latency
more rows red per second typically used
for real time serving use cases or you
can go for sdds which have higher
latency for random reads good
performance on scans and typically used
for batch analytics
so let's go for ssds as of now here you
have cluster id which is auto populated
you can choose a region so let's go for
our favorite one here where i can say
europe west 3 i can choose a zone here
and i can then choose how many nodes
would i want to use for my big table so
when you talk about big table service it
will have a cluster underlying which
will have various nodes which will
control your data throughput storage and
rows read per second so as of now let it
be just one node and that's enough for
our demo when we talk about performance
it basically tells you based on the
current node and storage type it tells
you how many reads can happen at
milliseconds so it says 10 000 rows per
second at 6 milliseconds you have writes
which are 10 000 rows per second or you
have scans which are 220 megabytes per
second storage which is taken care here
would be 2.5 terabytes and i can then
basically click on create now there is
also some option called replication
guidance which basically says
replication for cloud table big table
copies your data across multiple regions
enabling you to isolate workload and
increase the availability and durability
of your data depending on your use case
you can have big table which can be used
to have your data across regions
now you can click on create
with all your specifications chosen and
that's going to set up a cluster or you
can say a fully managed nosql database
which will give you low latency and
replication for high availability now
once we have a new instance you can
connect to it with the cbt command line
tool and for instructions you can click
on learn more here you can just click on
this instance id to see the details
again if you would want to look into
your bigtable setup so it tells me here
that we have one instance what is the
cpu utilization time how many rows were
read or written what is the throughput
and this is
auto populated based on your usage you
can click on monitoring and that
basically will give you different
widgets which will display information
for your cpu utilization what is your
hottest node depending on how many nodes
you have system errors automatic
failovers storage utilization and so on
you can click on key visualizer which
will allow you to look into your table
if you have already created some data
here and you can click on tables to see
how many tables you have added here so
that's in brief about your big tables
which is
one thing which we need to remember is
it's not good for all use cases
so should be used for low latency access
that is fast access and good if at least
data is greater than one terabyte for
smaller amount of data the overhead is
too high so big tables performance will
suffer
if you store individual elements larger
than 10 megabytes
if you want to store bigger objects such
as images video files then go for object
storage
and that would be a better option so
always remember big table is not a
relational database it's a nosql
database and when you talk about
multi-row transactions or online
transaction processing bigtable is not
the right choice
so it can be used for wide range of
applications especially when you talk
about your olap that is online
analytical processing so it is designed
to store key value pairs and there can
be different use cases so for example if
you are using something like cloud data
flow or cloud data proc
where you would want map reduce kind of
operations big table can act as a good
storage because it has very high
throughput and scalability and the best
thing is that it supports hbs api thus
allowing easy integration with apache
hadoop and spark clusters which you can
bring up using one more service which
google cloud platform offers which is
called cloud data proc
so big table is good for real-time
analytics
it's commonly seen in financial services
iot and others and if you are thinking
of
running interactive sql then
bigtable would not be the right choice
but the other choice would be bigquery
you should also remember that this
has a cluster running and you would be
charged if this cluster kept on running
so you have to be very careful in your
free account when you're using such
services now we have clicked on this one
so i can select this one and basically i
can look at the permissions i can look
at the labels i can look at inherited
permissions here i can also
click on my instance
which we created and either you can edit
or you can just do a delete so as of now
we will just delete this which needs you
to given that name so we'll say aua test
b d
and then click on delete so whenever you
are trying out different services the
first approach should be setting up
these different services seeing how they
work basically trying connecting to them
and once you are satisfied with the
initial test then you can plan your
actions and come back and use the
service for a longer duration now that's
your big table which is one of the
offerings we can go back into storage
and here you have other options which
are available so for example we were in
big table you also have an option such
as cloud data store now that's one more
service which is offered by google cloud
platform when it comes to storage domain
so google added software on top of
bigtable
which supports more than simple key
value pairs
when you talk about secondary indexes
instead of just having one primary index
when you talk about asset properties for
reliable transactions such as sql query
like language
so these
features or these services were added to
or on top of your big table which gave
birth to a new service which was
released as cloud data store so this is
where you have cloud data store and you
can select a client cloud firestore mode
so you can go for a native mode enable
all cloud firestores features with
offline support or you can go for clouds
data store system on top of clouds
firestore so these are different options
here and here we look at the api or
scalability engine support how many
rights it supports and so on you can
choose one of these and then you can
choose where to store your data so for
example if i click on this one then it
choose asks me to choose a location so
it says the location of your database
affect its cost availability and
durability choose a regional location
lower right latency lower cost or
multi-region location here i can
basically choose for example europe
and then i can go ahead and create a
database
so it says initializing cloud firestore
in data store mode services in eu3 this
usually takes a few minutes you will be
redirected to your database once it is
ready so if we compare the pricing
structure between cloud data store and
cloud bigtable always remember cloud
data store you pay for monthly storage
which is also in the case of big table
however here you are paying for monthly
storage for reads and writes
but in case of big table you are paying
for cluster when it is running so cloud
data store is a good option for small
data
infrequent access and it acts cheaper
when you talk about large amount of data
or big data and frequent access then you
are talking about crowd big table so big
table is cheaper when you talk about
larger amount of data so here it says
since your database is empty you can
still switch to cloud firestore
initiative mode to get more features you
could do that you could learn you could
say query by gql
as of now we don't have any data here
let's look at the dashboard which says
since your database is empty you can
still switch to cloud firestore in
native mode to get more features so this
is your cloud data store and it has many
features
which help you to work with your data
however some features or important
features of rdbmss were still missing
and
that's where google created
yet another big table based service
called cloud spanner now we can continue
working on cloud data store which
basically gives you one option to work
with your data
you can create an entity
here by clicking on create entity and
that basically gives you
options such as default namespace you
can give a kind you can give numeric id
and you can start adding properties but
to learn more about data store we will
learn about this in further session so
as of now i'm going to click on cancel
i'm going to go back to my data store
and this basically
let's go to data store option or i can
go into admin here which basically says
if you have entities you can import or
export them so let's go back and let's
again look into storage options
so as of now we were in data store
let's click on this one
so as i mentioned your cloud data store
which basically gives you some
additional features on top of your
bigtable but what google also did was it
realized that there was a need for rdbms
feature support that is there were a lot
of features now here we have created a
data store and it says your data base is
ready to go just add data you can create
entities start putting in data and then
you can go ahead and query this so if
you would want to learn more about your
data store you can just click on this
one and that takes you to the complete
documentation of native mode and data
store mode what is firestore in native
mode what is in data store mode what are
pricing and locations how you choose a
database mode what are the feature
comparisons what you can do what you are
allowed to do here what programming
languages can be used different regions
pricing and so on as of now we'll click
on this one and let's look at one
advanced service which google cloud came
up with when it comes to your additional
features of rdbms so google created yet
another big table based service called
cloud spanner now that you might not see
here but if you scroll down you should
be able to see your cloud spanner
in the options here or did we miss it on
the top so let's again look here yeah so
it is here and you can click on spanner
so cloud spanner was released in 2017 it
basically supports relational schema so
it offers strong consistency for all
queries
which can be sql based you can have
multi-region deployment
now when it comes to massive scalability
requirement and strong consistency cloud
spanner is a good option so it says
cloud spanner is a managed mission
critical globally consistent and
scalable relational database so if you
would want to use this then you will
have to enable this api which shows you
an option here it says try this api so
it's a managed service
so it is one of the google's most
expensive database services there is
also one more database service which is
cloud sql which can be used so when we
talk about your cloud spanner it is
fully managed relational database
service it is massively distributed you
can have millions of machines across
hundreds of data centers with support
automatic sharding and synchronous
replication it gives you low latency and
schema updates without downtime making
data high availability and reliability
so we'll learn about cloud spanner
with more details
later in other sessions now we can also
go back to storage and we can look at
the different options which we have here
so you have object storage you have
spanner you also have your sql based
service which is yet another managed
service offered by
cloud or google cloud i would say so
that's called cloud sql so this is
basically a service which allows you to
have fully managed relational mysql
postgres and sql server databases google
handles replication patch management
database management and other things
which are related to this managed or
fully managed database service
it can allow you to handle terabytes of
storage capacity with 40 000
iops with
huge amount of ram per instance so you
can click on create instance here and
then you can choose one of the database
which you would want to use so cloud sql
is a managed service you can choose one
of your mysql or postgres and sql server
say for example i choose mysql now that
basically tells me what is the instance
id it
sets up a password you can always change
the password you can change the region
you can choose your database version and
then you can also look at other
configuration options which talk about
machine type which will be used what is
about your backup and recovery
maintenance and all that and if you
click on create this will basically
create a fully managed sql service which
can allow you to straight away start
using mysql on cloud thus allowing you
to store your relational data when we
talk about storage options how can we
not talk about a data warehouse solution
or basically an option which allows you
to run your queries by directly updating
data so you can
use a data warehouse service which
google cloud platform offers and that's
called bigquery so basically you can be
looking into the
big data section here and here you have
an option called bigquery so this
basically brings ease of implementation
and speed so building your own data with
house can be expensive time consuming
and difficult to scale so with bigquery
you just load data and pay only for what
you use so it when it comes to features
you have
features such as capability to process
billions of rows in seconds and if you
would want to do real time analysis of
streaming data that is also possible
here so here we have clicked on bigquery
which basically shows you the option
where you can start typing your query
and test your data access for example if
i have uploaded some data so
it shows me there are some queries which
are saved here now i can schedule your
query i can basically choose the format
of a particular query by clicking on
this more
here i have an option which says add
data so i can pin it to a particular
project i can explore public data sets i
can create a connection so if i click on
explore public data sets then it takes
me to a page from where you can get
different kind of data sets which are
already available which you can put into
your bigquery and start querying your
data by default it shows that it is
aligned to my project and i don't need
to worry about it i can look at saved
queries if i have already saved a
particular query i can look at job
history i can look at transfers
scheduled queries and reservations so
bigquery basically
initially had its own version of sql
which was slightly different from
standard sql but in 2016 bigquery 2 was
released that supports sql 2011 standard
you can always select standard sql
now bigquery when it comes to pricing we
need to remember that the storage is
where the storage cost is very less here
approximately 0.02 cents per gb per
month
it is almost similar to near line where
you can also have low cost that is 0.01
cents per gigabyte per month there is no
charge for reading data from storage
when it comes to querying and that's
where the cost is incurred so one
terabyte per month is free and after
that it costs few cents per gigabyte so
this is mainly for high volume customers
there is a flat rate by pricing which
can be used so when you talk about
querying you can save your query results
you can create data set to store the
results now results are put in a temp
table in cache and after you you're done
with that you can delete data set and
delete all the data so when you talk
about loading data into bigquery you can
get the data from cloud storage
google drive cloud data store stack
driver stack
driver other options you have cloud
bigtable or
other web interfaces so you can download
from url such as csv json avro you can
create data set create table and create
from source by doing a file upload
so
10 megabyte or less files can be
uploaded using web interface as an
option you can also use command line and
then you can start working with
your bigquery
so
here you can also work with streaming
data by basically pushing in streaming
data into your bigquery which allows you
to add one record at a time now you
could use something like cloud data flow
which
allows you to use a particular pipeline
about cloud data flow we will learn
later so you can benefit from different
features of bigquery and thus use
google's offering to work on your
structured data or i would say data
which suits well in data warehouses
now these are some of the storage
related services which google cloud
offers
although we will learn about using
bigquery and running
or uploading some data by creating add
data set here
by say creating connection or
using a public data set so as of now i
have this you can also access the
command line to work with this but we
will learn in detail about bigquery in
later sessions now here you can scroll
down and you also have an option within
big data space and that is your data
proc so when you talk about data proc
this is
again a managed service which allows you
to run spark or hadoop jobs so
especially if you are interested in big
data workload so for big data processing
for machine learning you can always use
cloud data proc this uses compute engine
instances under the hood but takes care
of management
of these instances so it's say it's a
layer on top to spin up clusters it's a
managed service it's cheaper pay when
your jobs are running only it's fast
because it is integrated with other
google cloud services you have open
source components pre-installed and data
proc is integrated with yarn to make
cluster management easier when you talk
about data proc you can click on create
cluster and that basically allows you to
set up your cluster by choosing a
particular region which you would want
to use for example i'll choose
europeast4 here it tells what kind of
machines you would want to use and by
default it has populated
as the machine here which is 4 cpu and
15 gigabyte now since you might be using
a free account let's not go for the
high-end machine let's go for n1
standard 2 and then you can scroll down
it says what is the primary disk what is
the disk type and this one was for your
master machine that is machine which
will have the master processes running
then you have your
worker node configuration which tells
this will be let's choose a lower end
machine and we can choose how many
worker nodes you would have so it says
minimum 2 you can choose the ssds and
their capacity it talks about yarn cores
and yarn memory which will be allocated
and here we have
then option of clicking on create
so once you click on create this will
basically spin up a cluster
wherein you can
straight away start submitting jobs to
this
you can basically go ahead once your
cluster is ready you can go into the
cluster you can submit a job you can
choose a type which is spark or any
other application which you would want
to run and then basically you can use
this fully managed service which allows
you to run your big data clusters you
can obviously control access via roles
or access control list and you can have
access
as it is at project level or based on
your data proc cluster or even at your
worker notes
so we'll learn about data proc in later
sessions so as of now you see here the
cluster is getting created it says
the cloud storage bucket which it is
using is this one now i can click on
this and open link in a new tab it still
takes me into console but now it is
showing me the bucket which is being
used by your data proc cluster
this is the bucket which is being used
and it is being used for underlying
metadata which gets stored here so you
look at the cluster related folders you
can click in these folders and then it
can see what is the script output what
it is doing and so on now i can come
back here to my bucket
which will basically show me what kind
of buckets have been created so you see
data proc service automatically created
some buckets which will be holding some
data you also have some other buckets
which were created based on other
services which we used the access
control is fine grained in all cases
plus it also shows our bucket so
underlying it is using compute instances
it is basically using let's go here and
let's go to compute engine and let's
look into vm instances
so data proc which has spun up a cluster
is also using the vm instances which we
see here are running it is using the
buckets and it has made a cluster ready
to use so you can click on this cluster
and that shows me my cluster related
details if there are any jobs running
what are vm instances what kind of
configurations it has used
and you can look at different details
here you can look at the logs you can
click on jobs and that will show you if
you have
basically run a job on this ready to use
cluster so it says there is this
particular job which was run
which was a spark job you can click on
submit and this one tells you what is
the job id what is the region you would
choose for example we will again choose
for example europe quest 4 it tells what
is the job type so you can run all these
type of jobs in this cluster such as
hadoop spark pi spark hive pig presto
you can give your jar file so if you are
packaged your application is a jar you
can mention that here you can pass in
some arguments you can also say some
other jar files add some properties and
then click on submit which will run your
job on this ready to use cluster now
since we have tested it i can basically
go ahead and do a delete i don't want to
incur any cost on these managed services
which are running so there are a lot
more information about using these
services which google cloud platform
offers and we can continue learning
about these services as we explore your
google cloud console or even your
command line option
now we can come out of this one
by clicking on this menu and then we
have other options such as kubernetes
you have cloud functions you have your
networking related services monitoring
related services different kind of tools
what you have you have other big data
specific services which you can learn
about and for each of these servers
google has a very good documentation
available for example when you talk
about publish subscribe messaging system
it is a real-time managed service which
basically is a pioneer which was used
and now you have a famous service such
as kafka which is being used for your
publish subscribing or messaging system
kind of requirements
so to conclude about
google cloud platform services you can
always go to cloud.google.com
and look into the document section now
here you have list of different featured
products you also have list of your
different domains and services which
google cloud offers and you can learn
about all the different services which
are offered by google cloud here you can
click on featured products and that
basically shows you compute engine cloud
run cloud storage you have cloud sql
bigquery vision ai you can scroll down
and look at your artificial intelligence
and machine learning related services
platform and accelerators api management
so google cloud platform offers
different services in mainly in your
compute storage and databases you have
networking related services big data
specifics developer tools
cloud ai
identity and security
iot management tools api platform
and so on so basically learn about the
gcp services which google cloud platform
offers and in detail you can play around
with different services which are
offered by creating a free account and
as i demonstrated you can use any one of
these services quick start them
basically connect to them put in your
data or use a managed service to manage
your data and benefit from google cloud
platform thus
having modernized infrastructure for
your different use cases if getting your
learning started is half the battle what
if you could do that for free visit
scale up by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
hi guys today we've got something very
special in store for you we're going to
talk about the best cloud computing
platform available amazon web services
uh rahul i think you said something
wrong here the best cloud computing
platform is obviously google cloud
platform no it isn't aws has more than
100 services that span a variety of
domains all right but google cloud
platform has cheaper instances what do
you have to say about that well i guess
there's only one place we can actually
discuss this a boxing ring so guys i'm
opexia and i will be google cloud
platform and i'm rahul i'll be aws so
welcome to fight night this is aws
versus gcp
the winner will be chosen on the basis
of their origin and the features they
provide their performance in the present
day and comparing them on the basis of
pricing market sharing options the
things they give you for free and
instance configuration now first let's
talk about aws aws was launched in 2004
and is a cloud service platform that
helps businesses grow and scale by
providing them services in a number of
different domains these domains include
compute database storage migration
networking and so on a very important
aspect about aws is its years of
experience now aws has been in the
market a lot longer than any other cloud
service platform which means they know
how businesses work and how they can
contribute to the business growing also
aws has over 5.1 billion dollars of
revenue in the last quarter this is a
clear indication of how much faith and
trust people have in aws they occupy
more than 40 percent of the market which
is a significant chunk of the cloud
computing market they have at least 100
services that are available at the
moment which means just about every
issue that you have can be solved with
an aws service now that was great but
now can we talk about gcp i hope you
know that gcp was launched very recently
in 2011 and it is already helping
businesses significantly with the suite
of intelligent secure and flexible cloud
computing services it lets you build
deploy and scale applications websites
services on the same infrastructure as
google the intuitive user experience
that gcp provides with dashboards
wizards is way better in all the aspects
tcp has just stepped in the market and
it is already offering a modest number
of services and the number is rapidly
increasing and the cost for a cpu
instance or regional storage that gcp
provides is a whole lot cheaper and you
also get a multi-regional cloud storage
now what do you have to say on that i'm
so glad you asked let's look at present
day in fact let's look at the cloud
market share of the fourth quarter of
2017. this will tell you once and for
all that aws is the leader when it comes
to cloud computing amazon web services
contributes 47
of the market share others like
rackspace or verizon cloud contribute 36
percent microsoft azure contributes 10
the google cloud platform contributes 4
and ibm software contributes 3
47 of the market share is contributed by
aws you need me to convince you any more
wait wait all that is fine but we only
started a few years back and have
already grown so much in such a less
span of time haven't you heard the
latest news our revenue is already a
billion dollars per quarter wait for a
few more years and the world shall see
and aws makes 5.3 billion dollars per
quarter it's going to take a good long
time before you can even get close to us
yes yes we'll see now let's compare a
few things for starters let's compare
pricing for aws a compute instance of
two cpus in 8gb ram costs approximately
68 us dollars now a computer instance is
a virtual machine in which you can
specify what operating system ram or
storage you want to have for cloud
storage it costs 2.3 cents per gb per
month with aws you really want to do
that because gcp wins this hands down
let's take the same compute instance of
two cpus with 8gb ram it will cost
approximately 50 dollars per month with
gcp and as for my calculations that's a
25 annual cost reduction when compared
to aws talking about cloud storage costs
it is only 2 cents per gb per month with
gcp what else do you want me to say
let's talk about market share and
options now aws is the current market
leader when it comes to cloud computing
now as you remember we contribute at
least 47 percent of the entire market
share aws also has at least 100 services
available at the moment which is a clear
indication of how well aws understands
businesses and helps them grow yeah
that's true but you should also know
that gcp is steadily growing we have
over 60 services that are up and running
as you can see here and a lot more to
come it's only a matter of time when we
will have as many services as you do
many companies have already started
adopting gcp as a cloud service provider
now let's talk about things you get for
free with aws you get access to almost
all the services for an entire year with
usage limits now these limits include an
hourly or by the minute basis for
example with amazon ec2 you get 750
hours per month you also have limits on
the number of requests to services for
example with aws lambda you have 1
million requests per month now after
these limits across you get charged
standard rates with gcp you get access
to all cloud platform products like
firebase the google maps api and so on
you also get 300 in credit to spend over
a 12 month period on all the cloud
platform products and interestingly
after the free trial ends you won't be
charged unless you manually upgrade to a
paid account now there is also the
always free version for which you will
need an upgraded billing account here
you get to use a small instance for free
and 5gb of cloud storage any usage above
this always free usage limits will be
automatically billed at standard rates
now let's talk about how you can
configure instances with aws the largest
instance that's offered the 128 cpus and
4tvs of ram now other than the on-demand
method like i mentioned before you can
also use spot instances now these are
the situations where your application is
more fault tolerant and can handle an
interruption now you pay for the spot
price which is effective at a particular
r now these spot prices do fluctuate but
are adjusted over a period of time the
largest instance offered with google
cloud is 160 cpus and 3.75 tbs ram like
spot instances of aws google cloud
offers short-lived compute instances
suitable for bad jobs and fault tolerant
workloads they are called as preemptable
instances so these instances are
available at eighty percent off on on
demand price hence they've reduced your
compute engine costs significantly and
unlike aws these come at a fixed price
google cloud platform is a lot more
flexible when it comes to instance
configuration you simply choose your cpu
and ram combination of course you can
even create your own instance types this
way before we wrap it up let's compare
on some other things as well telemetry
it's a process of automatically
collecting periodic measurements from
remote devices for example gps gcp is
obviously better because they have
superior telemetry tools which help in
analyzing services and providing more
opportunities for improvement when it
comes to application support aws is
obviously better since they have years
of experience under their bed aws
provides the best support that can be
given to the customers containers are
better with gcp a container is a virtual
process running in user space as
kubernetes was originally developed by
google gcp has full native support for
the tools other cloud services are just
fine tuning a way to provide kubernetes
as a service also the containers help
with abstracting applications from their
environment they originally running the
applications can be deployed easily
regardless of their environment when it
comes to geographies aws is better since
they have a head start of a few years
aws in this span of time has been able
to cover a larger market share and
geographical locations now it's time for
the big decision so who's it going to be
yeah who is it going to be gcp or aws i
think i'm going to go for choosing the
right cloud computing platform is the
decision that's made on the basis of the
user or the organization's requirement
on that note i believe it's time for us
to wrap this video up we hope you guys
enjoyed this video and learned something
new that aws is better right no that
choosing a platform entirely depends on
you and your organization's requirement
hello everyone welcome to this session
on google cloud platform website hosting
and let's understand what google cloud
platform offers when it comes to your
web hosting requirements
here
we will learn about google cloud web
hosting
some basics of cloud computing
web hosting service providers what is
gcp and why go for it
different types of web hosting which are
possible a use case such as lush
and a quick hands-on on using gcp for
web hosting
when you talk about cloud web hosting
google cloud has the feature of hosting
a secure and reliable websites easily
it ensures customers and sites
protection the website is a is
hosted on a fast and reliable network
you can do more work for less price with
google cloud
now when we talk about google cloud it
is always good to know some basics over
cloud computing
now when we talk about cloud computing
cloud computing is basically using
resources which are provided by your
cloud service provider such as google
cloud and cloud computing basically
means using hardware and software
components to deliver a service on a
network now here users can access
files applications from any device
that can access internet so when we talk
about
cloud computing this is basically using
services which are hosted on the
infrastructure managed by cloud provider
when we talk about resources which can
be used that may include
big data services storage options your
computing options networking options and
various other services which a cloud
provider offers
cloud computing has various different
service models such as you have platform
as a service
software as a service infrastructure as
a service
also these days we talk about containers
as a service
and these are your different computing
service models which are being offered
by cloud service providers which allow
you for automatic integration with your
existing environment or if you would
want to benefit from modernization by
using a cloud providers infrastructure
you have different services which are
offered some of them are for auto
software integration
or migration
backing up and restoring data
scaling your storage capacity that is
going for an unlimited storage capacity
and using a resource provided by cloud
service provider benefiting from
reliability cost efficiency which is
offered by a cloud provider in this case
we are talking about google cloud when
you talk about web hosting service
providers there are various web hosting
service providers you have aws
you have squarespace ibm cloud godaddy
bluehost and google cloud
so what is gcp and why go for it
when you talk about gcp or as we call it
as google cloud platform it is set of
cloud computing services provided by
google that runs on the same
infrastructure that google uses for it
end user products like youtube gmail and
much more
when you talk about gcp there are
various reasons why anyone would choose
it for their use cases now let's look at
some reasons when you talk about pricing
gcp has better pricing compared to its
competitors depending on the services
which you would use whether that would
be infrastructure as a service such as
using compute engine instances and
running your applications on them or
might be a managed service such as data
proc
or bigtable or your big query where you
can have your hadoop clusters running or
store huge amount of data or even build
your data warehouse wherein you can
store structured data so there are
different services with gcp offers and
pricing has been a better option in case
of google in comparison to other
competitors
when you talk about speed and
performance it's very fast and increases
the performance of your project if you
use different services offered by google
when you talk about live migration of
apps this is one of the features which
organizations usually like which none of
other competitors are offering when it
comes to live migration of apps so there
are specific features for example when
you talk about compute engine there is a
feature stating live migration wherein
your resources or your instances which
are running applications would be
migrated during say maintenance from one
underlying host to another underlying
host without affecting your
application's performance and you can
benefit from that
when you talk about big data google
cloud has various offerings in big data
space and that's one of the advantages
of gcp in comparison to other
competitors you have different services
for your big data needs such as pub sub
for publish subscribing messaging system
or going for data proc which basically
allows you to spin up your hadoop and
spark clusters to run your different
jobs and so on so when we talk about
features of google cloud platform it
offers high productivity because you are
using the resources which are based on
the same infrastructure which google
uses for its own different use cases
you can work from anywhere provided you
have internet connection and you can
connect to the cloud platform and use
different services offered via web you
can quickly collaborate with different
teams or different colleagues working on
different projects which might be
sharing or using different gcp resources
you are benefiting from high security
and different encryption and security
mechanisms with gcp offers now there are
fewer sources or you could say data
which is stored or vulnerable devices
there is high reliability flexibility or
scalability which gcp offers and the
cost effectiveness really makes it as a
good choice when you would want to
benefit from infrastructure
modernization and using a cloud platform
solution for your use case
now when you talk about different types
of web hosting
google cloud offers three types of web
hosting you have wordpress now it is a
free and open source content management
system you might have used in past or
have heard about wordpress where a lot
of websites are being created it is a
popular web publishing platform to
easily set up blogs and websites and
thus used by organizations or even
individual users for having their blogs
or running their websites or promoting
their products
you have lamp which stands for linux
apache mysql and php
and lamp stack consists of linux apache
http server mysql and php and is used to
host websites and web applications
you also have your option of building
your own website so you can develop
website or web application with your own
code directly on compute engine now
let's look at a use case and understand
what happened here when we talk about
lush so lush was founded in 1995 it's
you might have seen this brand somewhere
in the streets it is a global cosmetics
retailer headquartered in uk it sells a
diverse range of fresh handmade products
lush had become a global brand with over
930 stores in 49 countries so the
challenges which were faced here was
traffic on boxing day caused website
crash for almost 18 hours and this is
something which had a devastating effect
on their business the previous platform
had no scalability option what was the
solution the movement of website during
the peak time was easy due to
flexibility of gcp platform with rapid
vm deployment on google compute engine
the environments were monitored and
destroyed in minutes so the team could
test and deploy at speed by using google
cloud sql lush took complete control of
its infrastructure and optimized its
systems for effective scaling overall
the platform resulted in lower cost that
led to a bright future for lush
cosmetics now what was the result of all
this
the availability during peak loads was
improved because of google compute
engines auto scaling feature the
infrastructure hosting costs were
reduced by 40 percent
streamline data center usage from 5 to 3
with google's high quality private
network really benefited lush and it
provided a flexible architecture and
scalability for future business growth
now what we have seen here is that your
google cloud and its web hosting
basically offers users to run their
websites or use a web hosting solution
that can benefit in more than one way
the simplest approach could be seen is
by
clicking and setting up a vm instance by
going to your console for example if we
go in
to the google cloud platform clicking on
console
and here the easiest way i could test it
is by
going to my compute engine
vm instances and here i can spin up an
instance i can click on create now in my
previous sessions i have also explained
about how you could create a template
and run an instance from that we can
also click on new vm instance let's call
it new instance
i will choose a region
for example frankfurt i will let it be
general purpose machines let this
machine be one virtual cpu core and 3.75
gigabyte ram if i am looking for a
heavier website which might have more
users logging in and so on then i can
choose a higher configuration machine
here we have the option to choose our
distribution so for example i can choose
ubuntu and then i can choose a
distribution version so it let it be
16.04
we can choose the disk size to be 20
gigabyte and we can use ssds or hdds so
as of now it is standard persistent disk
that is hdd and that should be enough
let's click on select
here i will say allow default access i
would say allow http and https
so that if i have a website content
hosted on this machine i can access it
over http now here you have management
options for your instance you have
security option which basically allows
you to provide a public key if you are
interested in using an external ssh
client to connect now i have used
puttygen and i have already created a
private key which is here i have also
converted that as a pem file and anytime
if i would want to use this key all i
need to do is click on puttygen where i
had earlier created this ppk file now i
can just do a load and i can choose the
key which i have here
and i can give the pass face click on ok
and that shows you the public key let's
copy the public key from here let's go
into our instance and i can give this
here that resolves the name so i have
the private key saved on my machine and
public key which will be pushed into the
machine i can click on create and that
should create my instance to which you
can connect using ssh from the console
itself or using a external client such
as putty which will then need the public
ip of this instance the ppk file what we
have and you can connect to this
instance what i can also do is i can
just do a simple ssh from here and that
will basically allow me to connect to
the instance
what we also need to remember is
each instance what we create in compute
is also having some default firewall
rules now i have connected to my
instance
i can click on sudo su i can log in as
root and here if i would want i can
install a particular service so let's
say apache
let's say apt-get install and then i can
say apache2 or httpd that is basically
to host your web application so i'm
installing this service
and here i can check if the service is
running by doing a service httpd
status or i can say service
apache 2 status it says it is already
running that means the apache web server
page will be accessible from http
provided my firewall rules allow that
now before we look into this we can also
for our instance look at the firewall
rules so here you have network details
now since we created an instance by
default google has created some firewall
rules which allow default http https
icmp your default internal access rdp
and ssh access and here it says
these ingress rules which allow incoming
traffic are allowed from anywhere we can
customize that as specific ip addresses
we can also look at egress which is
basically outgoing traffic and this is
again saying my machine can connect to
the external world in different ways
using different protocols so you can
customize these firewall rules as of now
i am going to let it be default now we
connected to our instance
from the browser and we were basically
checking
how you can use this browser by clicking
on this now what i can also do is
here i'm logged into the instance my
apache server is running so the best way
to check if the apache web server is
accessible via http
all i need is my
public
ip so let's copy this let's go here and
i will say http
slash
just give your public ip and that shows
your apache to web server page that
means the apache service has already
been run
now here it tells if you would want to
host a particular page
what you will have to do is
as it says here it is based on
equivalent page on dbn from which ubuntu
apache packaging is derived if you can
read this page it means apache http
server is installed at this site is
working properly now you can replace
this file located at var www.html
index.html before continuing to operate
your http server so this is where you
can change the particular page and you
will be able to host your web site on
this particular ec2 instance what we can
do is we can check this so we can go
into the browser and we can look in var
www and that has an html folder
look into this and as of now you have a
index dot html and that basically is the
page what we are seeing now i can click
on this one and i can see i have a small
html page which is basically showing me
what we are seeing on our web server
what i can also do is for now i can test
it out and i can put in a different html
page and see how that works
so we
had basically the page here in var
www and then we had the html folder
and in html folder
what i had was this index file so as of
now i just moved it and i put it in a
different location so if i look in my
home hdu
index.html
that shows me the complete html page
what we were seeing on our web server
and here it shows you what this page
would display if you run it
on your http it says apache 2 ubuntu
default page
it shows it works it shows the content
and so on so for just testing i move
this page out from this location and
what i did was i added a different page
here so that
page
if you look in html and then look in my
page dot html section i've just added
some basic details of creating html i'm
saying body i'm using maki
and then i'm closing this with html tag
now this is a simple html page which i
created
and now what i did was once i've done
this i basically did a service apache
restart so once you do that it will take
up your new page
and once you have done that now you can
access that by going to
your http
given your details
and then basically give your public ip
which we can get from here
and just paste it here now hit on this
so that shows me there is a mypage.html
i can click on this and that basically
shows the symbol page which i created so
as of now
this is my web page which i have created
and
this is hosted on my compute instance
now obviously we can create a more
complex website
backed up by a database use php
use mysql to store the data and then
host your website on a google cloud
platform service such as compute where
your actual code is running so we can
learn about your web hosting on compute
instances in further sessions
are you in the analytics space
have you ever wondered how data
processing in the cloud is changing the
analytic space
if the answer is yes
this is the course for you all major
corporations are moving data
infrastructure and computing to the
cloud to optimize costs
to make analyzing data seamless
technology leaders like google and
amazon are investing heavily in sas
tools on the cloud
google is a pioneer in this space
the google big cloud data and machine
learning platform provides cloud
databases managed hadoop and spark
services
with tools like dataflow and dataproc
the platform allows for highly scalable
and reliable data processing
the datalab bigquery and cloud machine
learning features make it a great choice
for business intelligence large-scale
analytics and machine learning
its best-in-class performance and low
cost makes google cloud popular and
sought after
technology giants like spotify and apple
have implemented the google cloud
platform at their organizations
and healthcare and consumer goods
leaders like phillips and coca-cola are
migrating to google cloud for their data
analytics needs
a google data engineer with expertise in
google cloud machine learning and
bigquery earns 102 000 per year on
average
and the demand for google data engineer
certifications has never been higher
simply learns google cloud platform big
data and machine learning fundamentals
or cpb100 course offers a thorough
overview of the google cloud platform
covering its data processing
capabilities with various use case
studies
it's the perfect course for data
analysts business analysts and data
scientists with real world experience in
querying etl data modeling or machine
learning
i.t decision makers evaluating the
google cloud platform have also found
the training very useful
the course will cover everything you
need to know about the google cloud
platform and includes eight hours of
instructor-led training
modules on big data and machine learning
with the google cloud
hi my name is randolph cale and i'm the
co-author of the google cloud platform
certification courses for google
i'm certified on the google cloud
platform an authorized google instructor
and the course advisor at simplylearn
i have over 40 years experience in the
industry spanning different roles from
development
managing cloud infrastructure to product
management i've partnered with
simplylearn to ensure that you have the
best opportunity to become certified in
various google cloud platform
technologies
gain hands-on experience on the cloud
and make you job ready
before we discuss the course and the
reasons it will help you let me first
introduce you to google cloud platform
when you use the google cloud platform
you are empowered to build test and
deploy applications at google scale
the move to the cloud is happening today
there is a broad industry adoption
when i teach classes i see the pace
accelerating across all companies
forbes projects a 19 growth rate to 140
billion us dollars on cloud services by
how can you move to the cloud how can
you make a career in this fast growing
part of the industry
your first step is establishing your
credentials in the google cloud platform
domain and you can do that by getting
certified
the google cloud platform fundamentals
course introduces you to the google
cloud platform and shows you how you can
incorporate cloud-based solutions into
your business strategies
the course is intended for solution
developers
system operation professionals and
solution architects planning to deploy
applications and create application
environments on the google cloud
platform
it is also appropriate for executives
and business decision makers evaluating
the potential of google cloud platform
to address their business needs
completing this course will give you the
skills and the confidence to take full
advantage of the google cloud platform
ecosystem
simply learn offers you extensive
training to help you understand the
platform
you get eight hours of interactive
instructor-led live online sessions
along with the course you receive a free
trial account with three hundred dollars
credit toward the use of google cloud
platform for 60 days the instructors are
google authorized trainers the content
is engaging and all the topics are very
well explained
with simply learn you'll be enrolling
for the online classroom plexipass which
gives you the flexibility to attend any
of the weekday and weekend batches
according to your convenience
another thing that's impressive is the
proactive teaching assistance where
experts resolve all your course related
project related or technical questions
while pursuing the course
so if you're looking for the training
and guidance you need to have a deeper
understanding about google cloud
platform products and services this is
the best course for you
with the course material labs and
authorized instructors with extensive
experience
i don't think you'll need to go anywhere
else
take charge of your career sign up for
simply learn cp 100a training all the
best to you so with that we have come to
an end of day 4 of cloud computing we
hope the session was informative and
interesting
should you find any concepts difficult
to understand or have any queries about
any of the topics covered in the session
then please feel free to let us know in
the comment sections below our experts
will be happy to resolve all your
queries and concerns on a priority
on day five of cloud computing week we
will discuss one of the major
applications of cloud computing the
devops and cloud computing so don't
forget to stay tuned to simplylaw until
next time thank you stay safe and keep
learning
you